from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find all the differences
between McDonald's in the US and China
this is food Wars
new season USA versus China I'm so
excited for you guys to see this and to
meet our new co-host tianrin USA versus
China let's go
drinks from McDonald's in China come in
three sizes small medium and big but for
some reason the medium is 444
milliliters which in Chinese basically
just means die die die which is super
unlucky so I guess they really want you
to either get the large or the soil the
drinks at a US McDonald's come in four
sizes the extra small where'd it go
sorry they forgot it the small the
medium and the large our large is 80.9
percent bigger than China's largest soda
let's see if that's true bound to be a
little bit in the lid
that is Blasphemous shame these people
shame this clown some of you over the
past several years has said something to
the tune of it doesn't count or it's
wrong because we add the ice reheat the
ice in there and that isn't a true
measurement which I don't believe but
fine for the first time ever I want to
measure this without the ice I'm solving
this once and for all so right away you
get even less soda let's get this up to
exactly 32 fluid ounces 32 ounces of
Coca-Cola in the supposed 32 ounce
McDonald's cup I'm so sick of this why
are they saying 32 fluid ounces look
just say 30 or 31 it's fine your move
McDonald's a fries come in three sizes
small medium and large American fries
come in three sizes small medium and
large we will now weigh our largest fry
so what about McNuggets here in China
you can only get them as an order of 5
or 10 which is really just two portions
of five that's cute China real cute here
in the US we have way many more nugget
options four piece for your infant six
piece ten piece 20 piece and our largest
the 40 piece all the math heads watching
will be quick to point out that this is
300 percent of China's largest portion
so here are all the McDonald's menu
items from China that you won't find in
the US here are all the McDonald's items
in the US you won't find in China oh my
god I've been staring at this for so
long this is incredible check out the
back it's an origami Apple this is the
best and see what we got a hamburger
mini fries a drink a corn Cup
[Music]
oh my God this is way better than the
Hamburglar what do I have to build Pond
as well this is
I'm too old for this anyway if you don't
want a hamburger you can also change
this out for a fish fillet or for four
pieces of nuggets you can also get the
corn cup changed out for apple slices
but they will cost you one quite extra
and with the juice you can have either
apple juice milk or water so only
healthy options here in China's
McDonald's okay now on for the toy so
this is going to take a while give me a
second
and then something flips out from behind
us groin in here it's coming together oh
it's a basketball hoop
oh my God this is ingenuity at its best
look we can play Hoops with this three
two one
I noticed that his Happy Meal even the
box was a toy in America our Happy Meal
box
is another opportunity for an
advertisement all new season of the mass
singer on Fox check it out Jesus this is
Shameless some of these kids remember
before the extra small fry found it more
nuggets a four piece apple slices our
toy is decidedly not a puzzle and when
Kermit the Frog was in there that was
weird okay what is this who what
celebrity was the fox oh it's Wayne
Brady okay I've heard of him look is his
head in here
oddly enough shows the Stark difference
between China and the US there's has
this puzzle to put together ours is an
ad for a TV show
okay so these are our exclusive beef
burgers here in China people mostly eat
pork so I think with the beef they've
really had to go the premium root so
you've got some interesting combinations
this is the German sausage double beef
burger but in Chinese the name is kind
of like the anti-vegetarian Tyrant so
they've got some pretty aggressive
marketing for this imaginarian Cruise
just pulsing his Peck side what is that
oh if this is what they call a German
sausage then I think the Germans will be
very angry here we've got a BLT double
beef Focus
oh
I'm so sad what is this this is like a
BLT sandwich that's been set at the
bottom of your bag for a week I'm
excited about these though these are the
Angus Max thick beef burgers now
McDonald's have done premium
collaborations with Michelin starred
chefs in the past and they even have
these really super fancy packaging look
at that double cheeseburger
wow look at that the meat Patty sicker
than my son that's a proper Burger
it was very meaty incredibly cheesy this
is the double cheeseburger so I can
understand that for the vast majority of
Chinese people they're understanding or
access to Western food May really come
from fast food restaurants so this is
probably the gourmet burger experience
for the vast majority of the Chinese
population in the US you can get a
quarter pounder with cheese what the
heck there was two two Taps this is the
special two top Quarter Pounder which is
apparently and we also have a Double
Quarter Pounder if you want to increase
the meat someone wants to get their
daily vegetables here is the quarter
pounder with cheese deluxe swimming in
mayonnaise we saw the United States
called the McDouble if you want slightly
less cheese and a double cheeseburger we
got you covered quarter pounder with
bacon every once in a while there's like
a quarter pounder and put bacon on it
and I don't really repackage it for a
celebrity and these are our exclusive
chicken and fish options so I want to
start you off with this which has since
become McDonald's best spicy Burger this
is the MC spicy chicken fillet
apparently it's 1 000 Shu which is a
Scoville unit and it's roughly
equivalent to the spiciness you get from
a spicy and numbing hot pot and those
guys are pretty spicy
hmm oh that's delicious you don't feel
the burnout first and then there's like
your tongue slowly starts to wake up and
it's like a frog in a pot it slowly
starts to realize it's being boiled
alive and by the end of this burger
you're gonna want that coke now this is
McDonald's best-selling non-spicy Burger
the grilled chicken sandwich which is
supposedly has no growth hormones in
their chicken feed
very heavy on the black pepper woof wow
I'm very excited about this this is the
crunch chicken fillet burger and in
Chinese the name is
it sounds like how it's supposed to say
car is kind of like crunchy and flu is
kind of like the juice kind of squirting
out so this should be both crunchy and
juicy oh that looks like a much better
piece of chicken
yes yes
I didn't get the car probably because
this has gone a bit cold but look at
that it is Juicy in there okay this is
the super spicy chicken fillet look at
this guy you know this is gonna be super
spicy it's orange
it's not out spicy
oh
yes oh
my God
it's very tasty finish that
and it's done
to the hospital you'll go and last but
in my opinion least the double fish
burger
chicken sandwiches there's something
that is newish the bacon ranch mcrispie
it's just okay there's also a bacon
ranch Deluxe Mac crispy Deluxe equals
more vegetables the mcrispie is
something that we ordered and they
forgot and then now piling on the
vegetables you got the mcrispie deluxe
spicy in the crispy this Rebrand the
crispy chicken sandwich should be them
the crispy
so McDonald's China has one roll option
which is this crispy pork and pickled
bamboo shoot wrap
that Stacy is nice and crunchy very
spicy wow
mmm it's spicy it's sour anything that
has Citron pepperhorn in it it's just
incredible here we've got the mug spicy
wings which come in portions of two four
or nine straight up I wish we had those
wings those wings look really good also
I don't know if you've noticed but the
decoration here on the packet this is a
collaboration with a streetwear brand
called clots or clot and it uses
traditional Chinese aesthetic so here
you've got the lucky knot which is sort
of like a symbol for good luck and
Longevity as Chinese as it gets and this
is also the same flavor as the MC spicy
Burger I don't know if there's an
accurate translation for this this is
literally called
about the same size as my palm a little
bit bigger the more crispy chicken
crispy wow
yes this is
very special we didn't think we'd be
able to get this today this is the spicy
Lobster flavored chicken tenders the
Chinese says which means you have to
shake it
oh let's try these babies there was no
need to shake it at all there's there's
no seasoning there at all it's just
literally it's it's just literally
chicken tenders
it's more of a an aspiration towards a
lobster though and we've got crinkle cut
fries oh how I've missed you nothing
beats a crinkle cut fryer in China we
have a bunch of different Barrel options
for example this one is the golden
arches buckets which actually didn't
come in a bucket they just put
everything into a box the name actually
is the reason why we got this because
McDonald's in China has officially
renamed to Zing gongman which literally
translates as golden arches and when
they did that they caught a lot of flack
everybody started laughing at them
nobody calls them the golden arches in
Chinese it's just McDonald's but legally
they are now known as the golden arches
featuring sauces you know what that
means Julie sauce talk here are all of
our exclusive sources garlic chili
that's pretty much it oh and no Citron
Source either that's an American
invention just like General Tso's
chicken but here in China you don't
really get sauces unless you ask for
them they come with the Nuggets Chinese
people expect food to be complete when
it arrives at your table you don't go
and add more sauce to it sauces in the
United States after more for dipping
Tangy barbecue spicy buffalo it's the
USA so you know we got that ranch honey
mustard honey which is not here I don't
know where it is mayonnaise which also
they did not include Mexican style salsa
these are our exclusive desserts I am
gonna try every single one of them we
can start with the Taro pie Taro is
kinda like a cross between sweet potato
and potato it's often used in desserts
in Asia you'll find them in everything
from pies to bubble tea
it's a bit like yam with a bit of jam
but it's subtly sweet for Chinese people
if you say a dessert is not very sweet
that's actually a compliment pineapple
pie also one of my favorites
that is
[Music]
I think I'm going to finish this well I
wanted to chew for a very long time
so here we've got the strawberry sundae
which has kind of melted already but I'm
sure it would have been amazing when it
first arrived in affogato and a matcha
flavored affogato and then here we've
got the mug flurries this is the
strawberry McFlurry with Oreo cookies oh
my gosh that is perhaps the most sinful
thing that you could have oh but it's so
good this is just a regular mcfry and
here is my all-time favorite mango
pomelo Sago flavored McFlurry it's very
different with the ice cream you still
got the uh the mango in there and the
pomelo it's very juicy it's tender like
little tiny Pips in there they kind of
Pop when you eat them oh just perfect
fried rice
in the US you can get yourself a
McFlurry with mini M M's for some reason
mini M M's taste better than regular M
M's I love mini M M's
hot caramel sundae it's classic then we
got this in China yeah I mean what's
more American than an apple pie look at
this thing let's crack that bad boy open
we got chocolate chip cookies shakes we
get three different types of shakes here
at a U.S McDonald's chocolate
classic chocolate strawberry personal
favorite
that's so good vanilla the classic oh
exclusive drinks include the fuse iced
tea we've got the minute made orange
mcfloats bubble tea soy milk
pure milk Ceylon black tea which in
China we would call Red Tea which just
confuses you for fun I'm gonna go back
to here because this is the only thing I
want to try out of all of them
it tastes like orange juice it's just
plain old orange juice the us to give
yourself a Dr Pepper a Fanta orange and
an orange lava burst lemonade we also
get frozen drinks get a frozen Fanta
blue raspberry or frozen Coke McDonald's
also has smoothies a mango pineapple
smoothie and a strawberry smoothie
they make a decent smoother tunnels as
you can see we have an absolute ton of
breakfast options here in China I think
McDonald's has done fantastic in this
regard because the Chinese treat
breakfast as a very special meal we have
a very similar saying to eat breakfast
like a king lunch like a prince dinner
like a pauper so starting with the
sausage McMuffin with egg always a good
way to start the day you can get this as
a double as well next we have the ham
muffin it's just literally a piece of
ham some lettuce and two muffins so I
guess this would actually be a hamburger
and get this as a double as well next we
have the grilled chicken muffin
yeah
this chicken's been sitting around for a
while next we've got the the crispy
chicken McMuffin so this is the
breakfast version
of the such a big chicken chop breakfast
in the US we have so many breakfast
options starting down here the
sandwiches Egg McMuffin and maybe the
first fast breakfast sandwich to ever
hit the markets sausage McMuffin sausage
and cheese if you had noticed this is
all on what we call an English muffin
because they're from England there's
also a bacon egg and cheese McMuffin but
the option that we have most for are the
scrambled egg Burgers scrambled egg
grilled chicken burger the scrambled egg
is very luminously yellow wow look at
that
very peppery they love their pepper hair
don't know so scrambled egg sausage
Burger you'll notice that buns are
different now we're no longer on the
muffins we're back to regular buns oh
it's squeezing out isn't it scrambled
egg cheeseburger this is like the
brightest Burger I've ever seen in my
life it's definitely very portable I
think that's one thing that McDonald's
has done very well because Chinese
breakfast traditionally is is not too
portable in the sense that you need to
sit down to a lot of meals like if you
want to eat
um one ton in the morning or if you want
to eat some soups in the morning this
you can just take and go and of course
you can get the scrambled egg German
flavor sausage burger at least I give
you two as opposed to just one tiny
sausage biscuits biscuits biscuits
sausage and egg biscuit so the biscuits
are the same breakfast sandwiches you
get in English muffin form but in this
biscuit form the American biscuit this
dry crumbly buttery biscuits there is a
bacon egg and cheese one for some reason
people in this country seem to want just
a biscuit and sausage but no sauce no
nothing this is as dry as if you'd go
into like a barber shop and take a
handful of hair clippings and just shove
them in your mouth this is their dry in
the US so we have something called
McGriddles and the griddles are
breakfast sandwiches where they replace
the English muffin and or biscuit with
pancakes so first of all they got the
McDonald's logo right there too
hilarious somehow to the miracle of
science was able to inject syrup into
these pancakes
Sensational you can get your McGriddles
in sausage egg and cheese and then just
sausage
onto what I was going to talk about the
kanji kanji is a very traditional
breakfast item here in China it's
basically just rice porridge and it's
something that is kind of like chicken
soup for Chinese people in the sense
that if you fall ill you're going to be
given one of these plain with nothing
this I think is with Century egg but the
century egg it tastes a little bit like
a blue cheese version of egg in that
it's kind of like egg that's gone off
but in a very nice way and this adds a
nice savoriness to the Congee you can
also get it with pickles and bamboo
shoots and if you're going to get Congee
then usually you need to pair it with
what they call an an Asian dough stick
this is what we call a yotyal which is
literally a stick of fried though these
are absolutely amazing when paired with
stuff like soy milk and of course with
congee
you know you need to eat these fresh
deep fried they are so incredibly crispy
oh wow well done McDonald's like 10
hours later these are still crispy I'm
very impressed but also a little bit
worried because there should never be
this crispy after that long I wonder
what they've put in here
last but not least my German sausages
again it's not just sandwiches you guys
we also have something
in the US the big breakfast which is
totally in disarray this is this is like
the advertisement for this breakfast I'm
sorry
the big breakfast with pancakes is good
hot cakes AKA pancakes there's no way
they're back there like ladling the uh
right there's no way they're doing that
these have to be pre-made and they just
heat them up right so hot cakes and
sausage oh and they both come with syrup
so you know we got to do
yeah we also have a morning wrap with
ham the the wrap itself is is basically
frozen solid we can exchange that with
sausage which is also Frozen it's almost
like a piece of art now like you're
supposed to look at it instead of eating
it wow Frozen in Time U.S McDonald's
have sausage breakfast burritos I mean I
can't even unfold I'm just like ripping
it apart they got scrambled eggs the
sausage it comes with Mexican style
salsa at McDonald's it's actually pretty
good considering that this is like
probably the furthest you can get from
something from salsa and still legally
called Salsa if you're not trying to
completely destroy your insides first
thing in the morning you can get
yourself fruit and maple oatmeal seems
like your breakfast is trying to escape
your body an hour later might actually
be able to hold this down
the options
so we have macarons right now we have
two different flavors chocolate and
berries these actually look really legit
pat yourself on the back this is really
good and these things are lamingtons
I've never actually had lamingtons
apparently they're basically Australian
sponge cakes which are covered in
coconut flakes and this is a lemon
flavored one
surprisingly addictive uh we have the
McCafe bakery at the McCafe Bakery you
get you know sweet treats not
necessarily for breakfast but probably
leaning more towards breakfast time but
bam blueberry muffin a cinnamon roll
with cream cheese frosting it looks like
a squishy
it most certainly is not and come on who
doesn't love an Apple Fritter an Apple
Fritter is a donut that tastes like
apple and it was shaped like it was just
squeezing someone's hand for some
strange reason these are our McAfee
drink options starting with the extra
milky latte without milk
a latte is two-thirds milk and then you
add oat milk in there I don't think we
can have much coffee
oh oh wow that is surprisingly good in
China oat milk has really really taken
off because a lot of people did not grow
up drinking milk a lot of Chinese people
are lactose intolerant and so oat milk
is definitely a very healthy alternative
that's why we have the extra strong
chocolate with oat milk you can also get
this without oat milk extra strong
matcha milk extra strong matches oh we
have so much matcha extra strong
chocolate smoothie extra strong milk and
vanilla smoothie and the matcha milk
with matcha jelly
we absolutely love matcha here in China
I don't know why
it tastes like grass
and Frozen grass coffees and coffees and
coffees and coffees a McDonald's has a
assortment of feature drinks espresso
drinks mochas iced lattes let's get all
that on the screen see all these things
this is the cold brew this is so strong
I think each of you should eventually
take a sip but you will not believe how
strong the cold brew is oh my God French
vanilla
that's the exact opposite this is like
so sweet mocha who doesn't want hot
chocolate first thing in the morning
hilarious people are buying that oh this
the premium roast coffee I know I'm kind
of distant on it but they're actual
coffee the actual McDonald's coffee I
think it's very good they're they're a
good contender in the coffee game I
think in the faster than coffee game
especially the horrible PR nightmare
they had when they like destroyed that
lady's crotch with their super hot
coffee it is a comeback story McDonald's
almost killing along with second degree
burns from boiling hot coffee to these
nice little fun Cafe drinks that would
happen
pour this all over my crotch you can get
the um iced coffee drinks they're like
this this is the mocha McDonald's in
China also has a late night menu they
only have one item but this is worth it
I got it last night these are marinated
chicken bones they don't sound very
appealing but the Chinese name is word
play on an idiom which kind of means the
highest level of artistry and when I
opened up this box
[Music]
I literally heard Angels going oh this
is actually a street food from some
place up in Northeast China called
xinyang Chinese people love fiddly stuff
and meat on the bone it's just that much
more tasty
ah still incredible even cold you know
the Box actually says marinated chicken
bones be careful what may contain bones
and you're actually supposed to spit the
bones out but I'm
having so much fun eating this thing I
actually eat the bones too it's spicy
it's sour it's sweet ah and just
absolutely Divine I can see how people
would be inspired after eating this
so McDonald's came to China in 1990 and
then it opened in Beijing in 92 and back
then that was the largest McDonald's in
the world they had 700 seats on opening
day they served 40 000 people and people
didn't go there for the food it was a
place to be seen like McDonald's was a
window to the West it was a Cosmopolitan
place to experience capitalism in a way
but over time it became a trendy hangout
spot for City kids after school they go
there to do their homework it still very
much is middle class I remember actually
when I came to visit China 20 years ago
my aunts greeted me at the airport with
bags of McDonald's and I was actually
kind of offended that they would bring
junk food to meet me as opposed to real
Chinese food but for them McDonald's was
the best of the best it was all the
prestige hey to me McDonald's if it
comes a fast food it is number one in
the US dare I say the world if you just
want a good hot meal where you know
exactly what's going to taste like and
get it and go McDonald's never fails
waiting in line getting it to drive
through to get it lickety-split now that
really they leaned really big into
delivery since covid Amanda McDonald's
is showing up right away and I love it
it's dangerous uh I can't remember the
last time I've eaten inside a McDonald's
so I usually dine in at McDonald's but I
find that in China they focus more on
delivery and they promise to get
everything delivered within 30 minutes
which they actually keep to and that's
incredibly impressive last night I
ordered the chicken carcass it took 28
minutes got a Big Mac earlier that was
10 minutes so they are very very
punctual they're also open for very long
from Seven till 10 pm and there are many
24-hour branches so extremely convenient
now McDonald's channels as an American
brand so they have American Classics on
the menu hamburgers chicken sandwiches
but they they kind of assimilated and
made popular the burger culture in this
country it's hard to say because I feel
like the American taste is McDonald's I
think McDonald's has actually adapted
pretty well to Chinese tastes besides
the spicy burger and wings and the
grilled chicken sandwich which have all
become best sellers McDonald's actually
uses chicken thigh meat instead of
breast meat in all of its chicken
burgers except for the McChicken I think
that's because Chinese people think
chicken breast is dry and they've also
got lots of time limited specials when
it comes to desserts like the manto
burger which is kind of like a Chinese
bun and even cilantro sundae McDonald's
everyone's going to McDonald's Burger
King's been going out to McDonald's
since what the 60s every Burger chain
try to
get some sort of edge of McDonald's
we're fancier we're got different
varieties of stuff McDonald's is number
one here now and forever the McDonald's
logo should be in the American flag damn
it so China is McDonald's second largest
market Buy store account after the US in
China there are over 5 000 McDonald's
locations but KFC has over 9 000 they
actually came here first so it's KFC
then McDonald's then a local brand
called ecos which does both Fried
Chicken and Burgers so they're really
just fighting an uphill battle
in China a Big Mac costs 25 Yuan a Big
Mac in the US costs 5.29 make it a Big
Mac meal with a medium fries and medium
Coke and it's 36 Yen if you want to go
large that's 4 Yen extra for a grand
total of 40 Yen if you're making a meal
with the medium fries and medium drink
price goes up to 9.29 upgrade that to a
large and it's 10.79 our Big Mac large
meal costs 86 more so our Big Mac meal
is cheaper but at the same time the
average daily wage of a cabbie in
Beijing is about 200 yen give or take
and so this would be 20 of their salary
so it's still not really something that
you would eat on a regular basis but
maybe splurgeon
let's talk nutrition this is that very
big mac again in the U.S it's 590
calories and all this stuff in China Our
Big Mac has 524 calories 26 grams of fat
45 grams of carbs 27 grams of protein
and 877 milligrams of sodium what if we
did a Cabo starting with the medium
fries this adds 320 calories to the meal
and all this stuff while a medium fries
in China contains 290 calories 13 grams
of total fat
35.9 grams of carbs we're not sure if it
contains any sugars
4 grams of protein and 252 milligrams of
sodium but you need some to drink and
the medium Coke to that and this kicks
your meal up another 210 calories we'll
do the same here's everything in a
medium Coke in China
148 calories that leaves the grand total
for the China meal at
962 calories while in the us the total
ends up looking like this 1 120 calories
and all this other stuff get a load of
that sodium though no from calorie
counts to portion sizes we wanted to
find all the differences between
dominoes in China and in the US this is
food Wars
[Music]
here in China Domino's comes in three
sizes the seven inch small which is only
available for two pizzas the fruit
Deluxe and the cocoa brownie hand tossed
only the nine inch regular and the 12
inch large in the US our Domino's Pizzas
come in four sizes small 10 inch medium
12 inch large 14 inch and the XL 16
inches no there's nothing on your screen
the pizza is in fact that greasy
we have three types of crust
hand crust hand tossed and the thin
crust and eight different crust options
including stuffed crusts which are only
available outside of the US the UK has
them we have a sweet potato
stuffed crust you see that the orangey
bit in there
I was pretty good actually it reminds me
a little bit of a moon cake in that it's
sweet and savory
stuffed sausage crust just a little
sausage peeking out the hole lettuce
crust and basically it's a mushroom it's
a variety of mushroom of which there are
many different species they're actually
poisonous so you need to cook them
properly if they're undercooked they
will cause hallucinations uh the
mushroom seller I met her husband
actually was poisoned four times and
once he saw a bunch of skulls either
side of him once he saw a mountain of
gold one other time he just beats up a
fridge and the last time he slept for
three days
it just tastes like wet mushroom
actually we do have mushrooms that make
you hallucinate in the US as well
although you can't get them at Domino's
salted egg yolk stuffed crust it's
recommended that this is paired with the
chicken pizza so you basically have the
whole family in there
not as delicious it tastes like a
million calories such a guilty pleasure
the meat floss stuffed crust it's not
the most appetizing name is it it looks
a little bit like lint but it tastes
like bacon cotton candy usually it's
made of pork but you can also get it as
beef or chicken or fish I don't think it
quite works and crushed when crust is
already so dry we also have something
called the double decker thin and the
double decker sick correct me if I'm
wrong I think this is actually the
double decadence from the UK
I mean it is pretty much a pizza
sandwich U.S dominoes we have five
different dough varieties a better way
of saying that is five different crust
options dough varieties yeah same thing
anyway first one down here is a
gluten-free crust and I want to note it
only comes in the small because from
Domino's perspective if you want
gluten-free pizza you're eating it by
yourself next is the hand toss the kind
of the classic style right everyone's
seen the hand tossed to me it's the
default setting after that this is the
crunchy thin cutting the squares and
there's a Tavern cuts for all you in the
midwest another crust dough variety is
the pan this is a thick boy only comes
in a medium and of course the last one
is the Brooklyn style which you only get
in the large or the extra large and it's
thin and also has these really big
slices I can't tell that's eight slices
right no six slices right so it should
be eight I don't know can someone in
post increase the contrast on that to
maybe make the lines a little more
obvious
odometer's largest pizza has a diameter
of 12 inches or 30.5 centimeters and an
area of
730.6 centimeters squared and costs 88
Yuan or
12.81 USD breaking that down our pizza
is 0.11 Yen per square centimeter take
our large 14 inch or
35.56 centimeter pizza with an area of
993.1 square centimeters that's
0.015 cents per square centimeter or
.096 Yuan that means our U.S Domino's
Pizza per square inch is roughly 12.5
percent cheaper than in China
our Domino's categorizes their pizzas
into three groups Indulgence classic and
value let's take a look at the indulgent
first French style liver moose ham Pizza
I'm not even sure what a liver moose is
I assume it's meant to be fraguar it
smells like fragra
boom
but it is weird with pizza man no that
should not be eaten with pizza that is
super weird why hmm no let's grab some
New Zealand lamb
it may be New Zealand land but they've
used a lot of cumin and basically turned
it into a lamb skewer definitely miles
better after that the sultan durian
pizza that is a really healthy big piece
of durian Abalone and scallop indulgent
Pizza I mean just why Abalone is super
expensive and it's popular in China
because its name sounds like to get
explosively rich so you'll often find it
served at weddings at Chinese New Year
oh let's clean our palette we'll get
some Australian New Zealand wagyu beef
I'd eat the beef by itself I'd remove
everything else crayfish and chicken I
think they've gone full Nola here
because the chicken are meant to be all
lean chicken and then we got damn crawl
that is too chicken and crawdads I love
New Orleans food so yeah I would
definitely try that Pizza South American
ribeye steak the Burdock prawn bacon
indulgent Pizza we've got peas we've got
prawns we've got some cherry tomatoes
this is the Japanese style eel pizza and
on the description it actually says may
contain soft bones eat with a care
well I've already tasted that here we
have the Australian slash South American
grain-fed dice beef so they either
weren't sure where the beef was sourced
from or if they run out of beef from
Australia they go to South America and
over here we have a pineapple shrimp
Pizza you know for those of you who hate
Hawaiian pizzas this must be so much
more triggering nah I think it's
actually worse than a Hawaiian also in
the indulgent lineup is a regular durian
Pizza this is actually a best seller it
costs nine Yen less than the sultan oh
yeah no that's great
oh that's delicious here we have the
okonomiyaki surf and turf look at that
that's actually pretty decent it's even
got the hurikake in tag look at that
these little super thin flakes mmm
that's decent well done no that's pretty
good
very meaty too bacon meat floss potato
pizza
and it is absolutely blanketed in meat
floss and a gigantic potato wedge it's a
little bit like the Hawaiian pizza
except instead of a juicy pineapple you
have sweet
bacon flavored cotton candy not sure if
like the Domino's us menu obviously is
not as robust as China's Domino's menu
but there are some specialty pizzas you
can get here you can't get there
including these first one here is the
extravagan two capital z's ah this looks
like a rebranding of what would be
called a supreme pizza here right now if
you hate vegetables don't worry you can
get the same pizza but just meet the
version we got sausage ham pepperoni
possibly hamburger
this could have been just a sausage and
pepperoni pizza and it probably would
have tasted the same I'm just saying
Philly Cheesesteak Philadelphia let us
know in the comments how insulted you
are that the sandwich that fares your
name is now in Pizza form and this thing
looks terrifying steak cheese like that
onion and uh green pepper oh and
mushrooms
but I don't want a whole thing of this
though I already just one bite I'm like
yeah I got it it's more than novelty of
yeah I guess it does taste like a Philly
cheese steak but also I gotta give this
whole pizza
the Cali chicken bacon ranch which I'm
gonna go ahead and assume is what do you
think chicken bacon some sort of ranch I
don't know what makes it California
no I'm not bad buffalo chicken in China
they had all these really interesting
flavor combinations I'm sure someone was
just you know really trying to capture
the breadth of Chinese tastes here
everything is like this exists somewhere
else sweetest in a pizza form case in
point buffalo chicken Haiti like wings
yeah do you want it in Pizza form no too
bad buffalo chicken uh another one here
spinach and feta
no because I've been bitten until
Saturdays no another specialty pizza we
have exclusive to us and not in China is
a Wisconsin six cheese which assuming
from the name has
go ahead and guess six cheeses and I
said Wisconsin on there because
Wisconsin is the cheese steak shout out
to Wisconsin on to our classic offerings
beginning with the Salted egg yolk
flavored chicken which as you can see
was very welcomed by the crew we were
already missing two pieces the Chinese
name for this is Golden Sands which is a
specific way of cooking The Salted egg
yolk so that it becomes a sort of frothy
paste that can be used to coat various
things it's a salty sweet
umaminess teriyaki beef potato pizza
teriyaki beef yes the pizza itself is
already quite starchy it's all carbs and
then a potato on top of that it's a
staple and a staple
most of these pizzas are sweet picking
Duck Pizza
I'm very conflicted about this I like
that they're representing us but this
looks very Blasphemous to me that
actually sounds amazing
nope nope nope nope Blasphemous no okay
never mind I'd still try it though here
we've got the tuna Seafood Deluxe not
that big a fan of seafood Pizza myself
truffle flavored sauce mushroom and
chicken pizza two types of mushrooms in
that pizza but note that the Truffle is
a flavored sauce so that's not included
as one of the types of mushrooms
hola no normal Pizza yes chorizo Pizza I
don't know why there's Peas on all of
the pizza but look I'm gonna take it for
just regular meat toppings yes chorizo
get in here
tastes like bolognese sauce but it's
okay I can dig it especially after all
this stuff I'll take anything and now
our value options beginning with the
Texas barbecue now the description says
it has Texas style meat I assume it's
ham again it's sweet but here it says
it's a barbecue sauce maybe a honey
glaze I'm okay with that the lychee
chicken pizza don't know why it's paired
up like that this is actually a pretty
nemarific Pizza the name is very punny
and it references a middle-aged Chinese
influencer who screams at the top of his
lungs
which kind of just translates to come on
many times people have said that I kind
of look like that guy and it's just I
don't know what to talking about there's
no resemblance whatsoever
all I taste is a lychee the potato bacon
pizza this is one of Domino's all-time
best sellers and the name in Chinese
actually says American style I don't
know this is what you guys eat over in
Yonder
nope here we go here's a taste of
America
land of the free
who am I to judge I don't know what kind
of potato wedges Americans like to put
on their Pizza Korean style fried
chicken
also with sesame seeds seaweed marinara
sauce and it looks like onions
hey that's a winner
winner winner chicken dinner veggie
Deluxe not touching it over here we have
something special these are our two
smallest pizzas the seven inches this is
the fruit Deluxe Peach blueberry jam
pineapple coconut gel
laughs
you know what's best it's actually meant
to be sweet if I've tried one dessert
pizza I'm gonna try the other one the
cocoa flavored brownie pizza with
brownie cubes and cocoa powder it's
actually not so bad it reminds me a
little bit of Nutella on button toast I
can dig it
still here man that's a lot of pizza we
at the U.S Domino's have sandwiches
specifically these seven most of them
are just versions of pizza
that are awesome sandwich form first one
would be the Buffalo chickens get a look
in there the chicken cheese and the
sauce the chicken habanero I like a
habanero thing because it has the sweet
and the spicy pineapple and jalapenos
together in one bite this one we're a
Mediterranean veggie feta cheese and
spinach is that something about a
training area I guess banana peppers
which I don't think exists outside of
the US oh the Philly cheese steak
it's it's like double depressing because
this
Philly cheesesteak
when being made this is like not what a
Philly cheesesteak is supposed to look
like why do this right over here we got
the chicken bacon ranch bro they were
generous with the ranch look at that
lots of bacon and chicken and the cheese
nice an Italian sandwich Mamma Mia
salami cheese ham and another salami and
of course what is more Italian than
banana peppers and the chicken parm
sandwich chicken parmesan which is again
an incredibly popular already well
established sandwich that Domino's for
some reason felt they needed to
deconstruct and then reconstruct in a
different way
I don't want any of these no sandwiches
here in China but what we do have is
ribeye steak
waiter
[Music]
oh whoa
that's a big piece of steak
hmm
[Music]
let's talk pasta and rice we have both
here are our pasta options all come with
spaghetti or you can pay one extra yen
to upgrade to penne
spag ball looks decent smells good a lot
of Bolognese on the pasta spaghetti
basil I'm pretty sure that's just a
carbonara here we've got a seafood pasta
with scallop and Squid Row here we've
got the rice options chorizo baked rice
you've got some chorizo you've got some
pepperoni truffle flavored baked rice
with chicken and bacon not gonna attach
that don't like my Truffles and just a
nice wholesome Curry Beef rice curry
sauce beef
rice what could go wrong no rice dishes
in the us but we do have our own pastas
four specifically this is the fourth
dominoes food Wars that I've been a part
of I want to Again State I think the
pastas at Domino's are an absolute
Abomination so if you're watching from
outside the U.S and you think this looks
weird you are correct this pasta is so
weird Italian sausage marinara I mean I
can't even break through the skin of
this thing come on man chicken carbonara
oh
it hurts my soul
pasta primavera whatever Primavera means
it ain't this and last chicken alfredo
both countries have wings in China you
can only get your wings in orders of
four unless you go for the wings combo
now here we have four exclusive flavors
Cantonese roast sweet in like a fruity
sort of sweetness and you've got that
barbecue smell
it tastes like Chinatown next we have
the Orleans flavor oh it's very spicy
wow
oh
my gosh
we also have the honey and the barbecue
flavored wings and I believe in the US
you just have them combined as a honey
barbecue but here we get an extra flavor
out of it I'm sure some of you might
have noticed our wings look a little bit
different a wing is made up of three
parts the drum the flat and the tip
usually it's removed because it doesn't
have much meat but here in China we love
fiddly food basically here in China we
love the tip so much that we even have
an entire dish devoted to just the tip
one thing I do love on the menu though
is the Domino's wings in the U.S you can
get Wing orders in 8 16 or 32. we only
have four exclusive flavors starting
down here got the hots
then the honey and barbecue
sweet mango habanero and last the garlic
parmesan on the presentation this is is
especially but they are very good I mean
I still get pizza over wings but the
earwing sides
Domino's wings not bad we also have
roast skewers now these are something
that are popular Street Foods here we've
got some chicken satay skewers we've got
beef skewers these also come in the land
version incredibly delicious and also
yeah
roast sausages I think these are usually
what kids like to eat I don't usually
see adults eating these these would be
sweet sausages but they're very filling
China also has Seafood options namely
our golden shrimp which actually look a
little bit orange Pollock bites and
regular fish bites our other sides
include chicken rolls I believe it's
smoked chicken mayo
an egg and peas as peas peas make it
into every single menu item here at
Domino's many hot dogs wrapped in a very
cute blanket it's almost like it outgrew
its blanket healthy salad star-shaped
hash browns onion rings
and potato wedges and both countries
have garlic bread but ours we do it a
little differently ours is stuffed with
cheese and other stuff for instance this
one right here jalapeno and bacon why
this
over Pizza another one we have here is
the spinach and feta we have twists we
have bites starting over here we've got
the Parmesan bread twists
looks like it's kind of like doing this
like please don't give me diarrhea
garlic bread twists
do you want this taking up space in your
stomach I don't just get more pizza I
mentioned it before we got dips what are
dips what I can tell just big portions
of something to dip these Breads in
first one is oh my good Lord gonna go
ahead and assume this is the five cheese
look at that usually look at the oil on
this
uh
[Music]
you know what it tastes like like pizza
but without the sauce and not to be out
done looks like the cheese one but this
one you guessed it
has
marinara sauce so if you got sick of
having bread with the sauce and cheese
on it you can just get the sauce and
cheese baked and then the bread bakes
separately and just dip them
who wants this instead of pizza I don't
understand but all right we have square
garlic bread and garlic bread I actually
don't know what the difference is beside
the shape but they both come with this
honey Mayo dip I actually thought
this was mustard
I think it's mustard mayo and honey I
think the bread is just an excuse to eat
this dick because this is actually
pretty good we also have soups you can
get a nice bowl of pumpkin cream bacon
classic washed or cream of mushroom soup
desserts unfortunately both China and
the US have lava cakes so it is not
exclusive but we have a couple things
that you can't get in China specifically
these
cinnamon bread twists and the Domino's
marble cookie brownie come on it doesn't
like brownies and you can tell they put
a little cookie dough in there it's a
cookie brownie hybrid and we got this
icing that you would dip in here and I'm
not gonna do it I I've decided I'm
taking a stand against all twists and
bread
not happening sorry here in China our
exclusive dessert options are limited to
Dorian pie I believe this is durian I
had a sniff vegetarian you can always
tell her something is durian just put
your nose to it pineapple pie
and we have one of two Portuguese egg
Tarts drinks in the US you can get
Sprite Fanta orange Dasani water and Dr
Pepper this is M Blick Leaf flower and
coconut jelly I had to do quite a bit of
research to figure out what an M Blick
is apparently it's some kind of fruit
that actually has a lot to do with
Buddhism but it has great Cooling and
cough relieving properties so this is
perfect for summer when it's too hot
outside
oh
it's kind of nice but it also kind of
tastes like I'm drinking green perfume
if that makes sense it's very very
Floral this is coconut and musk melon
mmm
oh that's tasty it's a little bit too
rich so nay to that and this this is
Karan Bella and Olive that's such a
weird combination right so a carambula
is this thing
it's a star fruit but I've never had it
as a drink and together with Chinese
Olive okay learn something new every day
oh that was a pleasant surprise there
was actually some coconut jelly at the
bottom too that was very inviting we
also just have a regular mango and
passion fruit drink oh and
bottled water
[Music]
Domino's entered China in 1997 but for
about two decades they pretty much just
floundered and nobody really took notice
of them it's only really in recent years
that they've become very useful with all
sorts of wacky flavors as you've seen
and because it's not as common as
McDonald's or KFC in China a Domino's
opening in for example tier 2 tier 3
city is big news to locals and a lot of
people actually post about it on social
media oh look Domino's has come to our
town it's something to be proud of
Domino's in the US I feel like it's been
Domino's versus Pizza Hut Pizza Hut
versus Domino's since I think the 80s
yes there's other Nationwide pizza
chains Papa John's sucked up a lot of
the attention online for a while there's
a little Caesar there's a bunch of other
ones but it really is Domino's and Pizza
have been neck and neck I mean they're
kind of interchangeable now people watch
are gonna be like no one's better than
the other down I honestly I don't think
I could taste the difference you put
them side by side but with dominoes as
far as a reputation you always know
you're going to get a good pizza a hot
pizza it's going to be decently priced
which is nice hey in China Domino's main
Rivals are of course Pizza Hut who
dominates the market with a 35 market
share next in line is a local brand
called Champion pizza with 5.6 of the
market share and third comes Domino's at
5.3 of the market share like in the
states Domino's China has a guarantee to
deliver your pizza within 30 minutes
otherwise they will give you all sorts
of discounts this really sets them apart
from other Pizza players here in China
because they use their own proprietary
delivery service whereas most
restaurants in China use a third party
akin to something like ubereats it's
also something that's become a bit of a
double-edged sword because people were
actively trying game their 30 minute
delivery window by switching off
Corridor lights removing door numbers
and just generally trying to get their
delivery drivers lost and about half of
all of Domino's salary payments go
towards their delivery drivers which
shows you how big of a delivery Force
they have which is actually kind of
quite nice convenience I mean Domino's
is probably one of the most convenient
uh Peter chains in the United States you
can get you can get a Domino's Pizza you
get in the app it's easy to use the
pizza's at your place in probably 30
minutes depending where you live some
would say too convenient
Domino's in China doesn't disclose their
nutritional information but based on
third-party independent research we
found that a large hand-tossed pepperoni
pizza has
1466.4 calories 64 grams of protein 66.4
grams of fat
155.2 grams of carbs and
3257.6 milligrams of sodium our large
pepperoni is 370 calories per slice or
2960 for the entire pie also
299 of your daily sodium
that's a salty pie Domino's China's most
calorific Pizza is this the large salted
egg yolk flavored chicken pizza with
stuffed sausage crust now one slice is
230 calories and the full Pizza is 1
841 calories our Domino's Pizza with the
most calories is the Kelly chicken bacon
ranch an extra large slice is 560
calories and the full pie 3 360 calories
two ingredients you won't find in
dominoes in China are potassium bromate
and ractopamine both have been banned
for use in China potassium bromate is
used as a dough conditioner as
classified as a category 2B carcinogen
by the international Agency for research
on cancer rectopamine is FDA approved
and it promotes muscle mass development
limits fat deposition and reduces feed
consumption although it is considered
safe for human consumption China
requires all meat sold to be free of the
drug and never fed the product to begin
with there is no direct link stating
rectopamine is specifically used in the
meat at Domino's but on their
stewardship page under Animal Care they
State quote it's important to highlight
that Domino's does not own raised
transport or process the animals use for
our products Domino's purchases pork
beef and poultry ingredients from
suppliers to obtain their products from
Farmers and ranchers who raise and care
for their animals in compliance with low
local state and federal guidelines
industry best practices and the support
of farm and animal veterinarians that is
a very long legalese way of Domino's San
a
we don't Farm to meet we buy them from
other people and they're saying they're
doing it the right way so
we don't know from exclusive items to
portion sizes we wanted to find out all
the differences between KFC and China
and the US this is food Wars
here in China we can get KFC in three
portion sizes one piece two pieces and
six pieces in the US KFC chicken comes
in seven portion sizes these first four
are one piece a la carte
two piece with a combo that's a side a
biscuit and a drink
three piece also with a combo
and the four piece also with the combo
and of course we have buckets we have
three main cool buckets the snack bucket
which contains five pieces of chicken
and six wings the family bucket which
gets you an extra corn on the cob
some mashed potato and three drinks and
the super family bucket where you get
desserts and mashed potato more of both
on top of that as well and then we have
buckets where you can get an eight piece
our 12th piece
or the 16 piece now if we're going
strictly on just chicken and not Wings
the u.s's largest is 166 Point repeating
six percent bigger than China's largest
chicken portion size next we have fries
now here in China we get them in three
sizes small medium and large we got two
fry sizes in the U.S the individual
and the large let's weigh the large
fries in both countries
I never grow tired of that here in China
our drinks come in three sizes small
medium and large American drinks come in
the following size as regular 20 ounces
and large 30 ounces but that's not all
you can also get a half gallon container
good the Jesus piece of any beverage of
your choosing
[Music]
hope you're sharing that Joe
here's everything you'll find in a KFC
in China that you won't find in the US
and we have a lot to get through here's
everything you'll find at KFC in the U.S
you won't find in China One exclusive
that we have here in China that you
cannot find in the US are wings
that's right it's tough times for the US
economy in just about every sector
earlier this year KFC laid off several
favorite menu items including Wings
Nashville hot sauce to anything
strawberry lemonade chocolate chip
cookies and pretty much popcorn chicken
they still exist in the famous bowls but
not on their own ah we still got them
here and they're available in two Styles
the crispy spicy wings and the New
Orleans grilled wings now you might be
wondering what are New Orleans wings uh
apparently KFC might have invented the
flavor and it's kind of like how
generoso's chicken is not actually from
China
New Orleans chicken is kind of just a
misnomer it's a honey baked spicy wing
with a I think a Cajun mix you as
chicken Styles one chicken style you can
get here in the US you can't get in
China is this the extra crispy that's
exactly what it sounds they fry it like
twice or with more breading I don't know
because that extra crispy crunch volume
up
foreign
in some parts of the country you can get
Kentucky grilled grilled chicken not
fried I mean fried's in the title so I
don't know what you're doing getting
grilled chicken at KFC
and for sandwiches we have a spicy
option I just wanted to talk a little
bit about our chicken recipes here so
this is the original recipe but we also
have an additional recipe called the
Golden crispy chicken now you can tell
that there's quite a bit of a difference
it is significantly more golden in that
I guess it's lighter yellow color than
the original
but there's also a very healthy
sprinkling of chili powder on top
and the batter is a lot harder and
crunchier I guess it's probably more of
a localized version of the chicken that
looks delicious that's like extra crispy
and spicy yeah I definitely want to try
that here we have our exclusive burgers
and roll we'll get to that later first
off I just want to draw your attention
to the Rattan pepper flavor
Spa chicken burger I had a really tough
time trying to figure out what Spa meant
and I found actually on one advertising
poster in fine print that Spa was not an
acronym it just meant that the chicken
is Juicy and tender because this is made
of chicken breast instead of chicken
thigh which you'll remember from another
episode is the norm here in China
because Chinese people think that
chicken thigh is Juicy and tender
whereas breasts is really dry and it's
basically chalky so I guess the spa is
an attempt to get rid of that stigma by
saying ah look it's so soft and tender
like the chickens just come out of a
massage or a spa treatment if you
haven't had hot pot or had such a
flavors before this might be a really
big turn off because the taste of the
Rattan pepper is so strong the chicken
is all right you know it's tender I
can't say it's just come out of a spa
the spicy chicken sandwich
looks basically the same or for one it's
not spicy and second is actually not as
tasty as the the spa chicken
I do actually not you know what I'll
take it all back I do actually feel that
the the spa chicken is a little bit more
tender this one does feel drier the
crispy chicken sandwich
it's pretty much the same as everything
else I think they're really just adding
different condiments but the gist of it
is always lettuce
the Mayo and chicken that's it and the
bun of course and the New Orleans
chicken burger of course they're going
to put this in a burger as well if
they've gone and invented an entire
flavor category that's actually not bad
and we have one more chicken options the
old Beijing chicken roll or as listed on
their website the dragon Twister so they
called it old Beijing Style
and I Now understand that old Beijing
means that you're going to Chuck some
cucumber in there there's probably leek
in there as well there's gonna be
tiemian sauce let's give the dragon a
taste
it just tastes sweet there is a crunch
from the Cucumbers but the Cucumbers
kind of gone a bit
it's kind of gone a bit sad as well now
we've got the beef burger options this
is the classic American style beef
burger
imagine this being like
the introductory course to American
flavors form someone who's never left
China they're going to be sorely
disappointed oh you can also get double
beef burgers at KFC in your classic
American style or cool no thank you or
the smoked pepper flavor
if you want a burger go to McDonald's go
to Burger King there's also a fish
burger the Deep Sea Cod Burger which you
can get as a double as well I do have my
hopes up for this one not very high
minded but I do have some hope for this
one this is the bacon wagyu beef burger
it's a premium Burger as you can tell
because it comes in its own box which
prevents it from becoming squished into
sandwiches like these guys
no no
I don't care if it really is Waggy or
not in fact it actually tastes a little
bit like the consistency of spam you can
get that as a double or a triple but
just skip it in my opinion we have one
exclusive sandwich to the US it's this
the Chicken Little which I guess is a
bite-size chicken sandwich full of
tender in here also
um hey KFC if I had one note maybe relax
in the Mayo on this are you kidding me
look at this the sauce whatever this is
like bro it is dripping now pickles not
a fan
why this over the chicken sandwich I
have no idea I mean unless you have like
a kid or a picky eater skip this we've
also got other chicken options beginning
with our Hong Kong style crispy big
chicken thigh if you've watched our
other episodes you'll know that Hong
Kong style usually is used to denote a
sort of a
sweet honey roasted flavor profile
would have been oven baked look at this
glaze that's beautiful
mmm it's sweet without being cloying
it's Savory it's incredibly meaty
there's also the secret recipe whole
chicken look at that an entire chicken
see it's about the size of my face and
I've got a pretty long face you've done
well you've done well colonel I forgive
you for the burgers heck yeah dude I
totally want one of those man just bite
right into that big leg like in that
medieval times this here is the hot and
spicy chicken with bone
and apparently it's scapular meat so
your collarbone I've never had
collarbone chicken meat so this is
definitely a first for me it tastes a
little bit like a chicken nugget but
with a bone inside and we've also got
popcorn chicken
and Nuggets you might be wondering what
these are KFC is trying to squeeze in on
the pizza business this is KFC's K Pizza
this is a chicken and mushroom K Pizza
look at that ultra thin crust well that
actually pretty good
I think I actually like this more than
Domino's pizzas and this one is very
special this is the K Pizza da panty
flavor
means big plate of chicken it's a
xinjiang dish which is usually a chicken
stew comes on a giant dish with potatoes
and bell peppers and you also get some
hand pulled noodles thrown in in fact
the original story of the big plate of
chicken supposedly was either invented
by a citronis or a hunanese immigrant
who was serving these dishes up to
truckers and they're very hearty they're
super tasty you always eat them in a
group but I'm just gonna pick out and
eat one by myself on a pizza hmm
FC this is legit good
KFC has recently added nuggets back onto
the menus to the technically
non-exclusive anymore but I'll show them
off here you can get them in 8 and 12
pieces here's the Nugget eight pieces
get in there you only nugget vision
now remember before when I said they
didn't have popcorn chicken anymore I
mean this is pretty
right it's a little bit bigger than
popcorn chicken when I said novice you
would probably think when I was thinking
like McNuggets right like nuggets this
being a nugget is very strange really
good though we also have chicken tenders
they come in orders of 8 12 and 16. the
crispiness in this I have to
[Music]
now to complement your chicken we have a
plethora of sauces and condiments to
offer namely sweet vinegar and sweet
chili which we couldn't find today and
the Citron pepper spicy chili powder you
can't eat this dried we have a bunch of
exclusive sauces and you know what that
means sauce time sauce talk started off
the buffalo ranch thank you nuggets
let's go
yeah the KFC sauce a really good
barbecue sauce honey barbecue excuse me
[Music]
classic Ranch I don't know what the
ranch situation out there in China is
but here we're doing all right with rent
the ranch situation in America solid we
also have a honey mustard sauce a honey
sauce and a hot sauce all three today
and they did not have here in China KFC
has something called the DIY kitchen and
they also have stuff from third party
vendors without further Ado let's dig in
first off we have the chicken nuggets
and the hot and spicy chicken with bone
if I was hungry and I wanted KFC
I'm gonna order KFC I'm not gonna go and
cook it myself isn't that the whole
point of take out of fast food it's
cooked for you if you're so inclined you
can also make KFC's famous egg Tarts at
home KFC is also offering
Secret Recipe Chicken fillets from a
third party vendor the whole cut sirloin
steak also from a third party KFC also
selling your pasta now they come in
mushroom and black pepper carbonara and
spag Bowl actually oh this is the spag
Bowl you've got your Bolognese you've
got various condiments yeah no to KFC
pasta no the KFC pasta no to the burgers
chicken is your lane stay in that lane
they've also got rice they come in four
flavors the original flavor chicken
Japanese style fried rice what's
Japanese about it I can't tell and this
one is the baked rice this one is the
French style roast chicken cheese baked
rice and probably the most
understandable of the offerings in the
DIY kitchen the ice cream so KFC have
partnered up with Oakley as you can tell
Oatley is just everywhere in China it's
so big KFC also has this
it's called the modern ice cream
although here in China we call it the
madir and it's got a really interesting
history this originates from a city in
Northeast China called Harbin where they
hold the ice and snow Festival if if you
know about that and basically modern
Harbin was more or less built by the
Russians
um the modern gets its name from a hotel
that was built by a Russian which also
had a bakery and sold yogurt and ice
cream so this has become an institution
especially if you go to Harbin in the
winter for the Sloan Ice Festival when
it's like minus 20 people are still
queuing up on the street to get yourself
one of these popsicles it's been a it's
been a while let's see if the ice cream
is still good to eat it does feel a
little bit soft it's like Frosty the
Snowman
once uh once Summer's set in you can
just have a peek
I'll be able to drink it soon
salvageable
what still is going strong in the menu
is the pot pie man this thing is hot I.E
I don't want to disrespect any of the
pot pie heads watching but I've never
seen anyone order this I've never seen
anyone eat this this thing is gigantic
you can't get this as a side so someone
in this country
assuming lots of people are walking into
Kentucky Fried Chicken and getting a pot
pie I don't know why you're doing this
pot pie is perfectly fine I feel like
this could totally go on the menu
if you want to fight me in the comments
go for it but I've never met a person
who gets this and eats it and uh this is
kind of my job we'll do a taste test
later as for now moving on the famous
bowl I don't think this exists outside
of America so let me go ahead and
explain it it basically is every side
plus popcorn chicken or in this case
nuggets in one thing mashed potatoes
gravy cheese corn and yeah bits of
chicken look I thought they don't like
all these things but together in one
dish is kind of so what you're really
doing is getting a side of mashed
potatoes and gravy and sprinkling some
cheese corn and Chicken on it I don't
know people are complaining on the
internet the famous Bowl's so good now
they have the mac and cheese Bowl which
is mac and cheese
with chicken on it and these are the
Nuggets remember I said before the
popcorn chicken is still in this in
isn't this popcorn chicken and these too
big to be popcorn chickens it's just
nuggets that have replace the popcorn
chicken I want answers
are fine and the American cheese too but
together they don't add anything
the only thing it's doing is being like
why get it in two containers just get it
in one Speaking of mac and cheese
exclusive sides in the US you you can
get your mac and cheese without chunks
of chicken in it just regular mac and
cheese uh our biscuits
oh so dry coleslaw
China you don't want this I mean how do
we even explain coleslaw
shredded lettuce shredded cabbage excuse
me all right I don't even know what it
is we want Mayo
and carrots and corn
like McDonald's KFC also has a late
night Street Food menu but unlike
McDonald's which only has one item the
chicken carcass KFC has four and
two different types of chicken carcass
I feel like the KFC version is maybe a
bit bonier so this is probably the
Citron version then
let's take one of these fellas out I
think preferable to the original this is
pretty interesting this actually looks
like original recipe chicken this in
fact is called the AO Al big chicken
carcass R is uh
is onomatopoeic and it's from the
northeastern region of China basically
it's slang for howling you know that is
gigantic and you're just you're dying to
eat it so Joe if you come to China and
you want to order this you know what you
got to do you just go up to the counter
and be like I want that
chicken got it and then they'll know
exactly what you want you can also get
fried chicken feet but we've done one
better and gotten the fried chicken feet
and fragrant bones box this is the
chicken feet obviously there's also
chicken neck there's chicken wing tip
scapular meat so all of the fiddly parts
of the chicken in one convenient box for
you to nibble on these are all of our
exclusive breakfast options okay so
first off I just want to draw your
attention to this KFC has so long Bowl
this is incredible because this is a
super popular breakfast item if you wake
up early you'll see lots of sellers sort
of with bamboo steamers about as tall as
you are it's filled with these sorts of
Little Bow the KFC xiaolong bar
oh that's even better than my
neighborhood breakfast place calling me
impressed I'm very very very smitten
with this plus they also provided a pack
of vinegar because you can't eat Bao
without vinegar next we have the kanjis
in terms of flavors we've got the
century egg and pork a staple Congee
this would be
sour pickle and chicken and over here
we've got the chicken and egg this is
the century egg
and pork and he goes I don't actually
like Century egg
it's stanky but not as stanky as the
like authentic Century egg and the
yotyao the crispy Chinese Cruller or
dough stick I mean there's so many
different names for this thing but this
is the heart of every Chinese breakfast
this goes well with soy milk you can dip
it in soy milk you can dip it in Congee
it's like a churro but not sweet
bit chewy these things are always best
right out the um the wok continuing on
with our Chinese breakfast this is this
is the super cute this is something
that's called a tea egg you get these in
one or four
and if it isn't considered
you're gonna have some yotel
and if you have any hotel you've got to
have some kanji
that's a trifecta it's the Holy Trinity
of Chinese breakfast we have the crispy
chicken spring rolls although
they've lost a bit of spring
I feel like one of those sausage finger
people from everything everywhere all at
once
I didn't realize we were in the uh
floppy crispy spring roll Universe
there's also a
chicken chop an egg Chinese style roll
although really this is this is more of
a wrap and what do we have in here we've
got chicken breast that looks like a
cucumber leek this is what's known as a
baltui which literally translates to
thin and crispy and it's meant to be
thin and crispy but it's more like thin
and flaccid right now I think this is
tiemian sauce which is um a sweet bean
paste I have to say this the Chinese
breakfast at KFC is next level I want
all of that are you kidding me all of
that looks incredible next let's talk
about the non-chinese breakfast so we've
got our Panini offering right here we're
gonna begin with the cheese and sausage
Panini just your regular I think there's
actually ciabatta bread now we've got
the cheese sausage and egg
the cheese and chicken panini the cheese
and thick omelet Panini now this is
interesting because this is a rolled
omelet I think in Japan they would call
it a tamagoyaki here we've got the
chicken chop sick rolled omelette double
Panini these three are special we've got
them just for you they're new offerings
on the KFC menu in fact KFC has been
really good at updating as many pretty
much every month they're going to have
new stuff this is their souffle lineup
the cheese and egg souffle Panini it's
basically
the same
achy thing but it looks like it's worked
out more in the gym it's got a better
pump next we've got the chicken chop and
egg souffle panini
I just want to do a side-by-side
comparison is it not the same thing and
I saved the fanciest of them all for
last this is the beef fillet egg souffle
oh look at that they even made it rhyme
okay it comes in its very own special
box
Okay so we've got the the fluffy souffle
and then there's mashed potato
in my panini and the beef fillet now we
have lefrench again
that was really bad I'm pretty bad at
the French hacks and sorry we have the
smoked chicken French style croissant
bread there's basically a cross sandwich
it's a square croissant with sesame
seeds and Le Bicken and ink French style
croissant bread the bacon and egg French
style croissant bread if my accent was
terrible not as impressed with the
paninis uh and we kind of got those here
and of course if you can't get enough of
the western style breakfast you can also
get single add-on items such as an egg
sunny side up you can also get a nice
juicy sausage hash browns
or is a must this is the egg and
vegetable soup here we've got the Hong
Kong style big crispy chicken thigh rice
this section beneath it is just
literally filled with rice and this is
the spicy meat sauce grilled chicken
rice here are two additional non-chicken
sides that we have
corn and wavy fries get a whole
chocolate cake to KFC
in the U.S I don't know why they don't
sell it by slices guess it's for the
whole family or whatever what can I say
about chocolate cake it's chocolate's
got frosting on it it's very good
I'm not gonna bite into it we're gonna
donate it so I don't want to screw it up
trust me it's good these are our
exclusive desserts let's begin with
KFC's best seller the Portuguese style
egg tart or just the egg tart for sure
and if you can't eat two whole egg Tarts
then you can go for the baby egg Tarts
oh look how cute they are they're tiny
KFC offers a basque cheesecake and this
is the red bean pie
that's delicious the KFC offers an
original ice cream cone but because we
got it delivered that's the cone
and this is the ice cream ah okay I
guess that's how I'm supposed to take it
out I'm just gonna drink the Ice Cube
here we go this is a first
oh oh oh okay okay all right we're gonna
put it back Sundays we've got four of
them
strawberry brown sugar and bubble sauce
I I assume bubble as in bubble tea this
here is the mango grapefruit sundae new
on the menu the North American blueberry
sauce here we've also got super soft
Mochi Sundaes this is the strawberry
flavor and this is the one that I guess
is basically the milk tea version
but with mochi balls on top following on
in the footsteps of the Mochi sundae
there's also a super soft KFC Mochi ice
cream which comes in four flavors this
one is strawberry ah no this one's
strawberry Oreo you can also get regular
strawberry Oreo and Tarot flavor
that's actually pretty tasty drinks we
got a bunch of them here in the US
starting down here something that is new
to America a lemon lime beverage called
Starry Sierra Mist is out starry's in
and
tastes almost exactly like seven up you
also get Mountain Dew oh yeah
a personal favorite Mountain Dew sweet
lightning I think you only get it at KFC
it's like Peach Mountain Dew
I know it's not good for me man it's so
good this is supposed to be a lemonade
but
is in fact more sweet lightning not
complaining but you also get the
Colonel's woman in and last but not
least sweet tea
oh yeah
a sweet tea
which is good love all these beverages
these are all of our exclusive drinks
let's begin over here with the most
Chinese of them all soy milk we have
Budweiser the
nine fruits orange juice then you've got
your milk tea with a very cute Colonel
Sanders and a bubble tea which is just
as cute and has the little tapio
composed at the bottom too over here the
three lemon tea consisting of lemon lime
and orange it basically just lemon juice
yeah I can see why it's called three
lemon
the heart warmings three black Goji oat
drink oh if you see that if you can see
the little bits of red stuff floating in
there it's got actual goji berries
it makes me feel like a middle-aged
Chinese Auntie with curlers in my hair
but in the best way possible I feel I
don't know I feel like I'm wearing PJs I
think was the snow Top Coffee
which is basically a nice latte with a
dollop of ice cream and this
also would have looked different when it
first arrived this is called the cute
bubble milk basically it's just straight
up milk with a layer of milk foam and it
would have had a smiley face dusted in
cocoa powder oh and I forgot to mention
there's also a hot lemon drink that we
weren't able to get these are the cake
coffees K coffees come in hot or cold
varieties you can get Americano your
standard latte your oat milk latte your
Rich milk latte your coconut latte then
you can also get the vanilla latte a
hazelnut latte sea salt and macadamia
nut latte and there's also your regular
cappuccino and caramel macchiatos
let's talk cultural Perceptions in terms
of prestige cavity really is the OG they
open in 1987 before Mackie D's and back
then they would have also been seen as
sort of a window to the West this fancy
Cosmopolitan place to be seen but over
time they've really become quite
entrenched here in China and they're now
seen as a foreign fast food brand that I
would say
has a lot of Chinese characteristics for
example the kanji the breakfast menu Etc
KFC's rap in this country they're number
one they're number one with fast food
chicken we got Popeyes we got I guess we
want to put Chick-fil-A but that's more
sandwiches as far as like
fast Chicken on the bone places Wing
Stop his wings and Popeyes and KFC
reputation is pretty much like you're
going to get a decent uh piece of
chicken and a lot of sides in terms of
convenience KFC has its own delivery
service but it also uses third-party
suppliers like everybody else but unlike
in the US where KFC is very much takeout
focused here in China they're more about
the dying in experience especially with
the extended family KFC is incredibly
convenient reliable I wouldn't hang out
at one or down there I would take it to
go one thing I should say about KFC as
much as they work on having quality
control you could tell if a KFC is good
or bad by like how dark the chicken is
when it comes out like the you know and
the one that we did today I don't think
they changed the oil
and in a while the chick was looking a
little darker than it should so that's
kind of like a thing you got to consider
convenience usually the service is
pretty quick but uh it's April 27th so
if somebody watching this happened to
get KFC from Uber or doordash on April
27th around 11 30 and your meal took
longer than you wanted
my fault uh our big order pretty much
backed everything up anyway so it's
usually convenient when you don't live
in a neighborhood where they shoot a
food Wars so in terms of adaptability
KFC as we mentioned before was the first
to offer Congee and Chinese krilla soy
milk on their breakfast menus also
unlike McDonald's which kind of played
up its foreignness a little bit KFC when
they came to the China Market had
high-level managers who actually spoke
the language and so they adapted very
quickly for example there are lots of
regional differences in terms of how
much spicy people can eat like people
over in Shanghai were complaining that
the spicy chicken was too spicy but
people over in Horn Island in central
China are complaining that it wasn't
spicy enough so they were very quick to
react and in KFC Kentucky Fried Chicken
Kentucky Kentucky to United States so
pretty much is local country tastes
um yeah they've been through the
Nashville hot thing they occasionally
bring sauces in and out but
Rivals KFC basically has none I mean
it's it's Numero Uno over 9 000 stores
doubled the market share of McDonald's
way way way far ahead in the distance
unless they sit on their Laurels they're
probably going to be cruising at number
one for a while KFC versus Popeyes I
always say KFC has in America at least
four times as many locations
yeah I think I think Popeyes tastes
better but
you know they're not I mean as far as
business is concerned KFC is not
sweating it
in China this spicy chicken burger is
19.5 Yen or 2.83 US dollars a U.S spicy
chicken sandwich is 6.99 or 48.10 U.N
that is a 147 price increase making a
meal add a medium fries and a medium
Pepsi and the cost goes up to 42 Yen or
6.10 still less than the cost of a
sandwich in the U.S our U.S combo with
tax is 13.75 or
94.61 U.N that is a 125.4 percent
increase compared to China our most
expensive single menu item is the Fried
Chicken bucket and Budweiser Meal which
is a 146 Yen or 21 and it gets you eight
spicy wings eight New Orleans wings and
four Budweisers I mean I
I don't know where the other three went
honestly they must have just gotten lost
on the road or something
in the US we have two menu items costing
49.99 or
343.97 U.N that's either the 16 piece
chicken meal or the 16 piece tenders
meal both come with four large sides and
eight biscuits
unfortunately KFC doesn't share its
nutrition data with the public but what
we do know is that in 2020 yum China
which owns KFC and Pizza Hut here in
China partnered with the Chinese
nutrition Society to research and apply
best nutritional practices for the brand
KFC in the US does have nutrition info
available here are a few stats alright
if you get the Kentucky grilled chicken
drumstick it's 80 calories crisp it up a
little bit with the original recipe or
the spicy now it's 130 calories want to
make it extra crispy like this one in my
stomach
now you've increased the calories to 170
that's 112.5 percent more calories than
the Kentucky grilled get real though
it's Kentucky Fried Chicken if you want
Grilled Chicken Go dust off your George
Foreman speaking of calories what menu
items have the most if you're going with
a chicken the extra crispy a breast is
530 calories sandwich the recently
discontinued Double Down has 950
calories for reference a Big Mac has
550. and besides the fries are the top
of the list an individual has 320
calories and in the family size which
let's be honest it's for one person uh
has 840 calories I've been informed that
my fellow producer Yuli song said that
their favorite thing on the KFC menu is
in fact the pot pie what a nice if you
said something while I was going off
about it
peas in it what else what else is in
here what is this from calorie counts to
portion sizes we wanted to find out all
the differences between lays in the US
and in China this is food Wars
[Music]
in China Lay's chips come in 14 that's
right 14 sizes coming in at our smallest
chip bag 12 grams 23 40 there's a 45 but
we couldn't get that 60 65 70. 75 grams
1890 104
135 and
220 grams for our largest chip packet in
the US latest come in six sizes there's
only four let me explain down here the
smallest bag is the multi-pack 28 gram
bag the vending machine bag move one up
to a 2.625
ounce or 74.4 grams so specific then in
the middle which I couldn't find is a
2.75 ounce or 78 gram bag in the middle
here the class I mean this is the one
you see everyone the 8 ounce or 226 gram
bag in the middle here missing is the
family size too tragic for the American
family they don't get to see see the
10.5
ounce or 297.6 gram bag but of course
the size that we always have Old
Reliable the biggest size the party size
368 grams that means the biggest bag in
the U.S is 67.3 percent larger than the
biggest bag in China it's not the size
that matters Joe it's
no wait no actually is the size in the
US our flavored bags weigh less than the
original flavored bags take this bag of
barbecued lays it weighs
7.75 ounces compared to the eight ounces
you get with the original bag same price
but less product back in 2014 PepsiCo
claimed quote the reason for the
slightly higher price per ounce for
flavor chips is the added seasoning
interesting so lace can you explain to
me why this bag of lightly salted chips
is 7.75 or 7 and 3 4 like the flavored
bags and that eight ounces of the
regular salted bags for all this has for
seasoning
is less salt than the original it lays
where's my salt a 28 gram bag in the U.S
supposedly contains 15 chips according
to Lay's website
huh let's see how accurate this is I
hate doing this I really hate doing this
we don't have a 28 gram bag so I'll
count the number of chips in a 40 gram
packet as a comparison it's 1.43 times
heavier
is it just as plentiful
four
ten eleven I'm I'm running out of big
chips now it's all the small ones
like a lot more than 15. closer to like
21. that was very generous of you layers
I see the Finish Line That's roughly 24
and
oh
25 chips in a 40 gram packet okay I'm
already incredibly impressed at the
number of chips they managed to fit into
this bag but they really could have put
more in there and we all know that lays
chip bags are mostly filled with air
anyway it's actually nitrogen gas which
helps preserve the chips and also acts
as a cushion to stop them from getting
smashed in transit I mean
okay but what is the air to chip ratio
you ask
it's a rhetorical question let's find
out I'm going to take the smallest
packet that we have the 12 grams so
that's
533.3 milliliters
I feel like I'm on the Food Network okay
now we need to find out the volume of
the chips 15 our ratio
is
0.028 chips to air which makes it 2.8
chips and the rest of it is all Air
incredibly scientifically accurate
experiment yields 575 milliliters in the
bag let's do
five bags and then we'll just get a
bigger number then divide that by five
because we'll have an average smart
great
oh yeah you guys have no idea how
satisfying this is
born in 25 divided by five equals
85. I forgot what it was can someone do
that on screen for us please
and there's the number we've been trying
to get
here are all the latest chips from China
that you won't find in the US and here
are most of the lace chips from the US
you won't find in China all right let's
start with the exclusive flavors for the
classic chip style now these four are
the most common flavors that you'll find
here on the Chinese market beginning
with Italian red meat wow it's nice and
red so we're probably going for
bolognese sauce here
it's not offensive
but you also can't quite place what
exactly they were trying to do next we
have the Mexican chicken tomato
oh that is delicious next we have the
Texas grilled barbecue flavor
it tastes Savory last but not least
cucumber flavor
why just why
I don't know what I'm eating what is
this it's sweet it's refreshing it has
an aftertaste of cucumber I want to ask
why
but I also kind of I'm okay with it it's
it's kind of nice you know I wonder if
these are popular because they're
foreign flavors because we don't know
what Italian red meat or Mexican chicken
tomato is supposed to taste like an
apparently neither do you guys all right
let's move on to our exclusive local
flavors
the spicy crayfish or as you guys in the
US would call them crawfish
yes
smells legit oh it tastes a little bit
less crayfish than it smells like
crayfish
no no that's good that's good oh it's
got that off to taste um wow that is
pretty authentic roasted cumin lamb
skewer hands down my all-time favorite
street food this is Iconic especially in
summer you'll see people hanging out in
the alleys with their tank top rolled up
so their belly is exposed we call that
the Beijing bikini here and then they'll
be holding a a bunch of these skewers
with meat just ripping them off and
slamming back the beers oh best things
about China it's street food honestly
it's there it's not as meaty as I would
like but then look it's a potato chip
all right I think they've done pretty
well what do we have here
seaweed flavor roast garlic oyster I
think they should just rename this
lineup to the street food Edition
[Laughter]
Wasabi flavor
oh
if you finish a bag of this
block nose go on
fried crab
holy crap
wow they've done really well
numb and spicy hot pot
it's spicy
I haven't got the numb yet maybe I need
to eat more the more you eat hot pot the
more the the broth simmers down the
spicier it becomes so at the end your
hot pot is way spicier than at the start
this feels a little bit like that right
now here we have another popular flavor
from the south from Citron this is roast
fish and we've got a special flavor from
a past season truffle
oh
okay maybe I'm just low brow I don't
like the flavor of truffle it tastes
like a wet Forest oh no thank you hold
this up we have a lot so many exclusive
flavors it's quite robust I was not able
to get all of them season ones I could
find here in Southern California first
one salt and vinegar
come on Jonah I like salt and vinegar
better than plain potato chips
Sweet Southern heat barbecue
different than our regular barbecue
sweet and barbecue flavor I think I like
these better than regular barbecue chips
let's compare regular us barbecue
Sweet Southern Heat
these are better
speaking of barbecue
honey barbecue
that's just okay you know this is not
very honey-ish if you want the sweet
it's sweeter than one honey
go figure oh yeah cheddar and sour cream
I mean this thing
no
top five over here these are really good
we got lemon flavored these are lime
flavor chips with I don't know who this
person is this is a guy in Ted lasso I
don't know who this is cesando
is that his name it's like a one
I have no idea what
yeah
what lime and potato together look at
that
I hate pickles
but I like Dill
but I should and Siri like this
nope yeah
go away forever do not like Dill
flavored chips they also have flaming
hot dill pickle chips couldn't get my
hands in a bag but I did get my hands on
a bag of just a flaming hot chips oh man
it's like really red
flaming hot
yeah
yep
spicy yes flavorful not so much ones I
think I'm gonna like chili them on not
as spicy way more flavorful oh yeah in
the lime aftertaste that is a fantastic
these might be my favorite
if I had to organize these in my
favorites these are my favorite these
are delicious these are all really good
everything to here on is like wood grab
do enjoy
the honey barbecue is not that sweet
flaming hot yeah hot but not really
flavorful until dill pickles pickles
suck you can also get the adobe's flavor
the Doritos Cool Ranch Lays
flavor and a cheddar jalapeno which I
really wanted to get couldn't get my
hands on I was really bummed all right
on to our regional Limited
starting with
the spicy chicken with rat and pepper
now this is a very popular dish from
Citron Province down in Southwest China
that Aroma is legit
very legit
this is way more numbing than the spicy
and numbing hot pot
and more spicy too the Hot Pot strikes
back this time it's the spicy hot pot
now I don't taste the beef oil in there
I don't get the Savory no this is my
sesame sauce hot pot
this is
Cantonese flavor ah
for once this is Sam turning roast Goose
flavor
oh oh well done
yes yes
huh Santan represent
marinated chicken feet linyi stir-fried
chicken now this originates from
Shandong province which is over in
Eastern China they're quite fond of
their stews and braises over there meats
and vegetables that have been cooked for
a very long time so hopefully this will
be very flavorful
okay so I can taste the sort of um a
roast meat flavor especially when you
cook with a Chinese Wok there's a bit of
smokiness that is attached to the to the
meat after you've cooked it I feel like
I'm getting that here we're back to the
Chinese flavors again this is um
it's called Las it's used so it's
basically stir-fried chicken in a
mountain of chilies you know that the
whole point of laity is not to eat tons
of chicken but to find chicken from
within the mountain of Chili's it's a
dish that goes especially well
with beer
there we go
we have another Hot Pot this I think is
the most pointless kind of hot pot this
is hot pot for people who can't eat
spicy or numbing hot pot for people like
you out there we have tomato hot pot
oh okay fair enough
it's quite tasty
now for our 2023 spring lineup beginning
with
oh
salt and pepper mantis shrimp
what do we have next oh Beef Wellington
oh my God
I I'm speechless
this leaves me very confused
it just tastes like butter and last but
not least we've got the
takoyaki flavored chips these are
Japanese Street Food
oh well oh the smokiness is on point
we have a bunch of Chip style varieties
in the US starting with another thick
chip variety kettle cooked I don't know
what it means I'm assuming they cook
them in a kettle I don't know how I know
how to make regular chips there's so
many flavors to choose from sea salt and
vinegar sea salt and Cracked Pepper
Mesquite barbecue jalapeno everyone in
the US I want to tell you right now
these chips fantastic these might be my
favorite chips these are so good
hmm
other flavors include original flaming
hot and Maui onion all right now on to
our selection of wavy and wavy Limited
beginning with our roast chicken wing
this feels thicker than the regular chip
very crunchy
I'm starting to get the roast chicken in
there that's decent the rose squid
not that big a fan of roast squid to be
honest but I will try
the roast pork
it's tasty but I can't really get the
pork in there I think the chicken is
still better this just says pure spicy
as if we haven't already eaten enough
spicy chips
and tomato nah nah this can stay
unopened moving on to our wavy limited
these are a collaboration with another
snack brand here in China called Huang
FEI Hong who make spicy peanuts this one
is
hot and sour chicken feet this is the
spicy peanut flavor for winter Huang FEI
Hong brand is best known
hmm tastes like spicy peanuts but in
chip form okay I'm from many of you must
be super curious as to what this is this
is Lay's choco Ridge which is a collab
with a brand that's literally called
lickic uh this is their cheesecake
flavored chocolate Rich I've never had
this either a sweet dessert place wow
this is so wrong that it's so ripe wow
wow
now I have very high expectations for
this now this is the choco Ridge
chocolate truffle here you can actually
see how it's literally just a regular
lays crisp
covered in chocolate well done um this
is a good collab we have something
similar our wavy style chips uh these
are three of the many options you can
get here in the US of course starting
with original we also have Hickory
Barbecue
this is like they combine funions and
wavy together always weird
let's get those you can also get wavy
reduced fat original wavy Ranch wavy
salt and pepper and wavy lightly salted
now onto our non-potato options of which
we have a lot
these are all yam yams have
subcategories of yam crisps and yam
rolls as well these are the black sesame
and chia seed yam crisp man they sound
healthy don't they so in traditional
Chinese medicine black sesame is thought
to help with hair growth I've been
recommended it a lot
now I can taste the nuttiness of the
black sesame
and I feel like my hairline is coming
back any moment now this is also
something that adheres to traditional
Chinese medicine Chinese dates and Goji
berries these are delicious
wow here we have pastoral tomatoes
roast chicken wing onto our yam rolls
these are an upgraded version of the
crisps that you see this is steak with
tartery buckwheat these things are so
wafer thin they have like this amazing
crunch the Airy the light the very
slight bitterness of the buckwheat lends
itself very well to the steak fragrant
red stew
consisting of yam and Highland Bali
which is the main cereal planted on the
specting high Plateau we also have tarot
and sweet potato chips
this one is with black pepper and sea
salt
it's very thin yet it's not crispy it
feels almost a little bit soggy
refreshing lime
what's with all the refreshing chips
sweet potato chips natural flavor
I know this probably frustrates some of
you at home but the majority of people
here in China open crisp packets like
this as opposed to horizontally like in
the west because it's easier to open
this way easier to share when you reach
in you don't get salt stuck to your hand
and it's also just less effort we don't
need to brew away our way into things
not gonna lie it's not so bad so we had
the regular sweet sweet potato chips now
we have sweet potato chips with added
brown sugar
oh
why no oh
I'm not gonna waste as little time as
possible on these big chips they just
for people who want their chips to be
more brittle and less flavored
I don't know they suck the original or
barbecue here's original I mean this is
the third time we've done this don't
bother just trust me don't bother listen
they're all destroyed in there just they
don't have no taste they're flimsy the
baked are bad there's the better for you
and simply brand uh the better for you
is a lightly salted lightly salted
barbecue wavy lightly salted all these
right here I get it sodium can be an
issue for snack and chips a lot so why
not go with the lightly salted uh maybe
I mean 50 50 less sodium that's pretty
good right I mean a lot of these I'm
curious
have this compared to them
there's a 50 less this is a hundred
percent less I don't taste anything also
the simply
I guess the whole deal is they just use
simpler ingredients
made with three simple ingredients
potatoes sunflower oil and sea salt
there's also the simply barbecue thick
cut
I mean how much better could it be we
also have two exclusives from the simply
lineup which have 50 less saturated fat
the refreshing lime and the seaweed
guess what we even have lays french
fries let's go with the
original flavor these come in really big
packets by the way
[Applause]
is so incredibly salty I am so glad that
the owners only gave us this tiny packet
because I'm gonna just no I don't want
the rest oh cheese and butter french
fries pink grapefruit flavor I mean you
can't
see this and not try it
[Applause]
this is really good
this is so weird but it's really good
hot pink grapefruit Lays
I'm gonna pick that up and eat it
that's that good
um
we also have seaweed flavor french fries
and
tomato flavor french fries but I am
dying to try this
Apple potato french fries
oh
I don't even know what that tastes like
no
now we have one more
non-potato chip Lays
the air fried chicken breast
I have absolutely no idea how much
chicken is in here it looks like very
tiny pizzas or little crackers
it leaves me very confused
do taste the chicken
but hey this is an interesting flavor
ah
Stacks stacks
stacks
have you seen any other lays food Wars
we've done I hate these for every reason
they are Pringle shaped chips in plastic
tubes instead of plastic bags first of
all
worst container right
does that sound like uh some chips are
uh intact
these chips are really messed up man not
a pleasant experience at all but I'm
contractually obligated to tell you
besides these two flavors you can also
get Stacks in Mesquite barbecue cheddar
salt and vinegar bacon and cheddar
potato skins buffalo wings with ranch
extra Flamin Hot flamas and chili lemon
please don't get them trust me they suck
we've got Stacks too and in many more
flavors as you can tell Stacks is
basically Lay's take on the Pringles but
whereas Pringles took 10 years to come
up with their saddle-shaped chip which
is actually known as a double curved
hyperbolic paraboloid
Stacks went with a single curved
hyperbolic cylinder so you can actually
see the difference
in the shape of the chip right here the
stacks by the way comes with a
fancy schmancy plastic tray that's meant
to keep it from breaking but hasn't
worked very well in this case here is an
intact stacks and here is an intact
Pringle to be honest they kind of look
similar the Pringle has an extra curve
down here whereas the stacks down here
appears to be a bit more flat now the
stacks also comes in tomato flavor
cucumber flavor there are some flavors
that I would love to try such as the
sizzled barbecue flavor
oh wow this is a good plastic tray
official right
black pepper
rib eye steak this I am actually very
excited to try finger licking red
braised poor there's maybe a hint of
pork in there
and some sugar and some caramelizing but
that's pretty much it
okay we've got one for you Stax fans out
there these are the stacks premium the
stacks black
the Chinese name actually says potato
workshop and apparently
it has real food ingredients
so this is avocado with mustard
why okay now we have purple potato so
basically sweet potato with
coconut milk
maybe it's an acquired taste oh
I mean you guys know I don't like
truffle now anyway I'm pretty low brow
but this is black truffle and black
pepper flavored potato chip Spanish ham
flavored potato chips I love me some in
bedok jamon
I am praying that this is gonna be tasty
fire them all the rubbish
this is spicy crawfish
hmm oh yes
okay finally we have a winner from the
stacks premium lineup this is great and
I would say that this
tastes even more authentic than the
regular potato chip version of The Spicy
crayfish that we had earlier oh
roast chicken skewer wagyu beef
sour and sweet rose petals
oh come on ladies you're just playing
with me now this is delicious
wow
imagine sitting in a nice warm milky
bath
floating with rose petals and eating
this sweet and sour rose petal lace
that would be the best evening ever wow
this is great fantastic
we have a seaweed flavor I like my
seaweed we've had too much seaweed today
I'm pretty sure this is going to be okay
we also got papable so these are so
stupid what is this we don't need a new
shape tell everyone in the biz we don't
need new shapes so I don't know what
this thing's supposed to be but you can
get it in sea salt honey barbecue
see some vinegar
white cheddar look at this it's all
hollow inside and
well
oh
it's like a giant checks
what are we what are we doing here Blaze
what are we doing here why what what
what what
I know lays seems like going hard on you
guys but I have to say ending with the
dips lace dips are fantastic they have
three to choose from
the smooth Ranch the French onion and
the creamy jalapeno couldn't get it this
French onion dip
drugs any chip works with it let's do my
favorite Kettle jalapeno
Stellar this dip works on literally
everything
I would put this in my coffee if I could
it is so great
fantastic the dips are great check them
out
a 75 gram bag of American classic ladies
in China is 7.3 Yen or
1.06 dollars our closest size to the 75
gram bag is the 74.4 gram bag so 0.6
grams less and it's 2.48 or 17.04
um that is a 134 cost increase in the
U.S right but then if you take into
account purchasing power parity then
lays charges the highest price in the
world for its chips here in China
so here in China even though the chip
Market only accounts for 15 of the snack
industry lays accounts for 50 of that
chip Market these guys are definitely
the creme de La Creme when it comes to
potato chips here in China and they've
got such a wide variety of flavors that
you will see them always in a prime
shelf location in every convenience
store across the country lays in the US
lasers like the chip right there's other
chip brands for layers probably the most
ubiquitous you see them everywhere they
have so many different options and
styles I think any type of potato chip
is even remotely popular lasers and
knockoff version of it always good
always available
always decently priced I guess I think
lays has been incredible in adapting to
the Chinese market they've basically
gone and found all of the popular
flavors and combinations in China
whether it's street food or restaurant
food and put them into a convenient and
portable chip packet laser is incredible
at adapting because as you saw before
every like style they have besides a
regular potato chip is a style that
another chip brand hand that they just
took on the kettle chips that they taste
just like Miss Vicki's they got the wavy
ones which was Ruffles right
um the poppables which I don't know
bugles checks you tell me any
three-dimensional chip the stacks which
is going after Pringles I mean they
they're bloodthirsty this company they
will go after anyone
our classic lace aka the American flavor
are made of potatoes oil American
classic original seasoning which is
comprised of edible salt monosodium
glutamate five flavor nucleotide
disodium and silicon dioxide
our classic lays are made up of potatoes
vegetable oil which is canola corn
soybean and or sunflower oil and salt
now there are two ingredients we wanted
to highlight which are monosodium
glutamate AKA MSG and five flavor
nucleotide disodium these two
ingredients are used to give our chips a
Savory Umami flavor ah MSG hits the uh
black sheep of condiments now for those
of you who don't know what MSG is it's
used to add savoriness to food and was
also associated with something called
Chinese restaurant syndrome which has
since been debunked many times turns out
it was a hoax but basically the gist is
when you go to a Chinese restaurant
after eating its food you'll feel
headaches dizziness sore throat loss of
appetite you know MSG is not a culprit
it's naturally occurring in tomatoes and
Bone broths it's found in fermented
foods from cheese to Worcestershire
sauce to soy sauce awesome actually the
vast majority of MSG in the world is
made through fermentation just like
yogurt or vinegar MSG was a cause for
health concerns in the U.S for decades
and concerns still lingers today even
though the FDA considers the addition of
MSG to Foods as being generally
recognized as safe Gras both countries
use the food coloring caramel color in
our barbecued chips now certain types of
caramel color contain a byproduct called
4mei full methylamidazole
and studies found that it caused cancer
in rats and mice which led to campaigns
calling for it to be banned from foods
but it's also worth noting that this
byproduct is found when you roast foods
like coffee and meat and the FDA was
like eh it's fine
humans don't come close to the levels of
exposure that cause the rat tumors that
didn't stop the state of California
adding it to its Proposition 65 list of
chemicals quote known to the state of
California to cause cancer or
reproductive toxicity End quotes
a 30 gram packet of China lays American
classic flavor chips contains
162 calories
1.7 grams of protein 10.5 grams of fat
of which 5.3 grams are saturated fats
15.1 grams of carbs of which 0.4 grams
are sugars 0.8 grams of fiber and 170
milligrams of sodium a 28 gram bag of
classic glaze in the US contains 160
calories total fat 10 grams of which
saturated 1.5 grams carbs 15 grams and
170 milligrams of sodium we did find
that the 160 calorie chips with the
highest fat content are the cheddar and
sour cream chips here's what's in a bag
of those 160 calories 10 grams of fat of
which 1.5 are saturated 15 grams of
carbs and 170ml kilograms of sodium
we have a very shocking Discovery
apparently lays healthiest chips or in
fact their least healthy in that they
have more calories on average than any
other lace product here in China and the
worst offender
[Applause]
oh is my hair growth serum the black
sesame and chia seed yam crisp now 100
grams of this will equal
598.7 calories or
168 calories for a 28 gram packet now in
a 30 gram portion you'll have
179.6 calories 1.6 grams of protein
13.3 grams of fat of which 6.6 are
saturated fat
13.7 grams of carbs and
212 milligrams of sodium which means
that the healthy yam chips are on
average 11 percent more calorific than
any other Lays chips containing less
protein and carbs and more sodium and
fat
you know I always thought healthy just
meant not tasty but in Lay's case
apparently it also means less healthy
what a plot twist
from calorie counter portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Burger King in the U.S and in
China this is food Wars
hey it's Joe I'm busy working on some
cool new videos for you and not be able
to host today but I want to introduce
you to my good friend Nico I trust Nico
is going to do a fantastic job all the
food Wars heads watching make her feel
welcome take it away Nico
here in China all about the king drinks
come in three sizes small medium and
large in the US our Burger King drinks
come in four sizes value which we
weren't able to get small medium and
large let's see how much our largest
drink actually contains I'm kind of okay
with it
they're lying to me our Burger King
fries also come in three sizes small
medium and large our fries come in four
sizes value small medium and large let's
weigh our largest runs 120 140 grams
Liars again
this is the second lie I've been told in
like five minutes I think Joe and Harry
have beef with Burger King ever since
hashtag frygate2020 they discovered the
small and medium sizes were the same
size allegedly allegedly I do not want
to get sued but let's see if both of
them actually do weigh the same I don't
think that I have to count every
individual fry because that is a very
big difference I think there's clearly
some discrepancies going on just for fun
let's weigh these value fries these are
98. what's happening what's going on at
Burger King so I guess you can get away
with just ordering a value size for like
way less money if this is what's going
on all chicken fries come in one size
only and should contain six fries
no way to escape from giving us the full
amount here because only six of them
ours is also one size nine chicken fries
one two three four five six seven eight
nine this is the first time the Burger
King hasn't lied straight to my face
let's begin with our beef burgers we can
start with the king's collection which I
guess are BK's premium Burgers whereas
the Whoppers are known as Emperors but
they're cheaper than the Kings I can
just hear the nationalists starting to
get angry already How could a cling be
more powerful and more expensive than an
emperor what gives obviously haven't
localized properly BK you need to know
your audience beginning with the
pastrami Angus it's not something that
you see very often here in China to
begin with so in Chinese the name is
called the big mouse Angus burger
because the burger itself is meant to be
quite a tall burger but this is a very
beautiful burger and I must say I am
very impressed that it has not come to
us sloppy and completely crushed into
paste which was the case that we found
with other fast food chains I'm not
gonna name names
very dense I did have to open my mouth
pretty wide and I can't quite taste the
pastrami but I like that it's there here
we've got the classic Angus you can also
get the spicy version which is what I've
opted for
oh that's a spicy palette this is
actually pretty interesting it's not the
Citron spicy kind of heat that I've
gotten used to here eating other
localized burgers in China but this is
more sort of a straight up in your face
heat a lot of black pepper and the
caramelized onions oh they pan very well
in this burger introducing the heavy
cheese beef thing so heavy actually it
even crushed the box that it came in
right hello the spicy bamboo shoots beef
chicken Whopper that is such a long name
it came in this box these are characters
from a massive game in China called the
honor of Kings it's a MOBA the company
that makes this bought Riot games which
made League of Legends the fact that it
has this collab I mean that means
something
I just want to say it tastes very
Chinese in the best possible way it is
feels like I'm in Southwest China right
now
playing a game of honor of kings and
losing badly
because otherwise how would I have time
to eat burgers if I'm not respawning
final member of the King collection is
the Italian spinach bacon Angus oh one
thing that irks me a little bit about
bacon in burgers in China is that
they're this kind of bacon they're wet
and what's the point of eating bacon if
it's not crispy
oh my God BK burgers are so incredibly
dense they're like the burger versions
of diamonds moving on to our classic
burgers this is the king oyster mushroom
beef Whopper Thai Basil flavor oh my God
not only are there Burgers mouthfuls but
so are the names you could actually see
the oyster mushrooms look right here
let's give this mouthful a mouthful
refuse to come in the gym about to do
some really heavy lifting
and then
another classic the grilled pineapple
Whopper one gigantic pineapple ring
if I had two more hands so oh the pork
cubes and beef burger who names these
things the pork cubes that it refers to
is
book neck the meat lovers heaven isn't
it I could do this
feeling like my jaw is about to break
oh yes
wow
that is amazing this pork neck is just
absolutely delicious moving on to our
value section we've got the spicy
Whopper Junior oh look at this little
guy you can also get the pineapple bacon
Whopper Junior also in this size this is
our bacon corner so we have the bacon
King and there is a bacon cheeseburger
and a double bacon cheeseburger I really
want to taste the bacon King
big burger for fast food right that is
heavy too my face is bigger but it
doesn't smell as good as this Bergen
does
kind of tastes like a burger right off
the grill this is like insane how big
they are now let's move on to the
Whoppers I think these are definitely
Burger King's claim to fame it's what
they're most known for this is the Texas
Double Whopper this kind of looks like
the Mondo Burger from Good Burger
that is not ASMR what's the opposite of
ASMR and the last Whopper we have is The
Impossible Whopper which I actually
think tastes pretty delicious it's like
this looks like a hamburger from like a
play food set I had as a child it just
doesn't look very real
this looks like a monster I do want to
take a bite of the Texas Double Whopper
just because it's got a lot of stuff in
it
that is so good oh my gosh really spicy
and here we have our single Rodeo Clown
King Burger
single Rodeo Burger King pounder all of
them share the exact same words it's
crazy and here we have the single
quarter pound king and the Rodeo Burger
which I think has onion rings in it I
was wrong okay pretend I said the
opposite so this is the Rodeo Burger and
it's got onion rings and what looks like
sticky barbecues on it's just a little
congealed in there
I think it could be good it's just not
very good now let's move on to the
chicken sandwiches or Burgers whichever
you prefer as for chicken you can get
the chicken Whopper coming in classic or
spicy flavors you can get the grilled
pineapple chicken Whopper as well next
we've got the Chicken Big King now the
Big King is a collection and we have
beef which is not exclusive here in
China but chicken and fish are and it's
basically kind of like a Big Mac in that
there are two patties and a bun in the
middle
that's a lot of red this here is the
fruitwood grilled chicken burger spicy
chicken powder the chicken is
threatening to escape
oh yeah the more you chew it the more
you chew it the more flavorful it
becomes and now I can it's it's almost
like a thermometer in my mouth I can
I can feel the spiciness rising up I
swallowed just now and my saliva is
spicy we have the crispy chicken
sandwich but what makes this a sandwich
and this a burger I have no idea there's
also a double version of that
excuse my lettuce that is called the
double chicken burger so if it's a
single it's a crispy chicken sandwich
but if it's a double then it just
becomes something else anyway this also
comes in original or ratan pepper flavor
here we have the chicken version of the
Italian spinach bacon Whopper a surprise
for you
this is new on the menu
The Black Cheese and crispy chicken
sandwich so this thing is not Nori this
is actually a slice of cheddar cheese
that's been dyed black with Squid Ink
because just why not so if you thought
this was weird check this out
this is the black cheese and crispy
chicken burger
most importantly instead of the the bun
that they've replaced it with two pieces
of black cheese mind blown
I think this is basically just an excuse
for you to not feel guilty about eating
a piece of spicy chicken by itself
without the bread it's basically
just there as like tissue to help you
eat this thing we have two chicken
exclusives the original chicken sandwich
and the chicken Junior This shape is
actually very unique and pretty iconic
in a world of circular chicken
sandwiches like this stands out to me
usually the chicken sandwiches I see
look like this just you know nothing
special but this
special BK also offers fish exclusives
here we've got the fish and crisp which
I believe uses a Cod fillet and of
course the fish version of it's a Big
Ang and of course we also have a pork
section comprising of two burgers the
pork neck and beef burger which I took a
nice big chunk out of before and the
chicken version of this pork burger and
here is our fish option the big fish
this is the smoothest bun I've ever seen
I know shiny and beautiful that is
is not offensive not particularly great
these are all exclusive snacks here in
Burger King China I feel like they're
encouraging on KFC territory a little
bit because all of this is chicken we've
got the Mahala chicken drumstick so Mala
literally just means numb and spicy and
it's referring to the citrani style of
cooking with the peppercorn which gives
you the numbness and the chili heat oh
wow
I feel like this is probably
the strongest
Mala flavor that I've had thus far on
food Wars starting to turn my tongue
numb and quite pleasantly surprised here
we got the petite version the Mala
chicken wings this here the king hot and
spicy chicken wings
oh man I much prefer over the Mala to be
honest this is a lot more balanced it's
more flavorful it's meatier so these are
called The Spicy flavor chicken slices
apparently it's four millimeter thin
slices of chicken breast it just kind of
looks like mini chicken nuggets doesn't
it this is the chicken box which
contains a medley of what we sampled
earlier so Burger King also has other
versions of the bucket the Box whatever
you like to call it they've got the King
chicken bucket the king bucket and the
King bucket plus they're basically the
BK version of the party bucket or family
bucket for those of you who could not
get enough of The Black Cheese you can
also get it as a standalone piece just
one piece of good old cheddar cheese
dyed black with Squid Ink oh BK we are
so funny
you can always opt for the garden salad
and here in Chinese it actually says
mama is shouting at you telling you to
eat more veggies and these are our
exclusive side options we have onion
rings
Don't Mind If I Do
you're soggy
and we also have mozzarella sticks which
I feel like at this point are fully
congealed back into their like frozen
state
these were supposed to come with a
marinara sauce I don't think I got one
we also have Mott's applesauce as a side
but they unfortunately ran out and here
are our
exclusive sauces sauce talk we have
Buffalo Ranch honey mustard and zesty I
know what pretty much all these sauces
taste like except for zesty I'm very
confused as to what this could be I'm
gonna Swatch this one for you guys just
so you can see what it looks like on my
skin tone
this is the most disturbing stupid thing
I've ever done
horseradishi I feel like zesty gives me
like ooh zesty this is like oh
let's see it's nasty time for desserts
we can start with the Ovaltine King
Fusion this comes in original strawberry
and brown sugar bubble flavor
the oval teen was the little sort of
brown flakes on top that's what tastes
like milk chocolate not bad it's not as
sweet as I thought it would be Ovaltine
King Fusion brown sugar bubble Edition
very elusive Instinct where are they all
right here we go
hmm
delicious Once Upon a Time this was the
Hokkaido flavor ice cream waffle cone
it's like melted ice cream I can't tell
if you say socato
I'm none the wiser this is the crispy
chocolate and nuts sundae Haagen-Dazs
Ben and Jerry get out the way BK's in
town look at that that looks Lux and
look at how much chocolate is in here
this is basically half a bar chocolate
in ice cream there's nothing that could
be better than this I think it's peanut
I'm not sure who cares oh it's delicious
and the strawberry pulp sundae actual
strawberry in the sundae Color Me
impressed this pie comes in two
different flavors dark chocolate or
mango and coconut let me check which one
this is I think it's a Telltale sign I
think it's probably the chocolate deep
fried chocolate what could go wrong
these are called crispy sick milk bars
it's creamy but it doesn't really taste
like much this is the soft Mochi ice
cream and it comes in two flavors
strawberry yogurt and salted egg
wow
it's kind of like a custard
this kind of tastes like what would
happen if he took the heart out of a
moon cake and liquefied it and just
drank it oh my god I think I'm seeing
stars from my blood sugar spiking
let's talk about desserts at Burger King
in the U.S you can get a soft serve cup
a soft serve cone or the Hershey's
Sunday pie this was one of my favorite
things ever as a kid I would always get
it every time we went to Burger King
look at this it literally says yum on
every side because it's that good they
look exactly the same as when I was
little
that is so
delicious these are the exclusive drinks
on the Burger King China menu looks
weird doesn't it just looks like seven
up but this is actually coconut flavored
lemon sparkling drink peach flavor
oolong tea this is the brown sugar Boba
milk tea you can get this hot or cold
and also if you take away the bubble
balls it will just basically become the
Hong Kong style milk tea which you can
also get hot or cold
the crispy chocolate low top milk tea
you can also get Ceylon tea which is
just black tea or hot or cold soy milk
which this is you can get juice too
grapefruit juice and mixed berries juice
next we have the king coffee collection
and this is just honestly the cutest cup
ever you can get your latte or your flat
white your hazelnut latte or cappuccino
and there's very very cute squat cup or
if you don't like being cute you can
just opt for a regular sized Americano
drink exclusives in the US include Coke
Zero Sprite Zero barks root beer Dr
Pepper Fanta orange Mellow Yellow
Powerade Zero High Seafood punch and
high C pink lemonade it's a fast food
restaurant so of course they also offer
milkshakes and Frozen beverages we have
a vanilla milkshake a chocolate
milkshake an Oreo milkshake a chocolate
Oreo milkshake this is a frozen Fanta
wild cherry and this is supposed to be a
frozen Coke but it's another Frozen
Fanta Wild Cherry we've been putting the
people at Burger King through a lot
today so some mistakes were made they
also supposedly offer a strawberry
milkshake but that wasn't available at
our Burger King
as a better vanilla milkshake all right
let's try this Frozen Fanta Wild Cherry
is this this is basically just a slushie
right that's very good these are Bug
King China's exclusive breakfast menus
okay so just like McDonald's and KFC
Burger King also does a pretty decent
breakfast menu here in China not quite
as extensive as KFC and nowhere near as
exhaustive as McDonald's but what Burger
King has over both of them is the cross
sandwich I love crossover sandwiches
although it's kind of weird how in China
they're not cooled by their actual names
but they're called croissants so this is
the standard cross sandwich the or as we
call it here in China the pork egg and
cheese croissant next we have the
Pastrami and scrambled egg croissant in
Chinese we would call it Yao tea which
kind of means like western style of BK I
mean obviously it's Western Star but the
fact that you know you have pastrami and
scrambled egg this combination just
seems very very foreign to Chinese
culture and I think in a in a cool way
this is great just staying true to BK's
roots
hmm I love pastrami I would have got
here then beef egg cheese croissant and
last but not least in our croissant
series butter croissant which is
all right BK you made this a seasonal
menu item I don't understand what it has
to do with Seasons there's literally
just two pieces of your cross on bread
this is the double egg and beef burger
two eggs with two beef batties
sandwiched in between no bread
whatsoever oh there is no way you can
safely get away with eating this without
making a mess of yourself now on to your
more standard fare the grilled beef
cheese muffin you can also get this
grilled beef cheese egg muffin oh now we
have something special the tamagoyaki
and fruit would flavor grilled chicken
muffin look at that
oh this is delicious well I highly
recommend it and if you don't want beef
in your muffin you can get it as a
cheese egg muffin if you don't want egg
nor beef then you can get it as a
grilled pork muffin BK also has an
assortment of breakfast wraps the
scrambled egg and cheese sausage wrap
Beijing style roasted chicken wrap no
Lee
just the cucumbers and the tiemian sauce
we're missing the last item on the Holy
Trinity of the Beijing style wrap
you know it's it's inoffensive that's
all I can say this is something special
salted egg yolk chicken wrap The Salted
egg yolk is actually smeared all over
the chicken here Ah that's very
ingenious of BK
there's no mistaking that salted egg wow
texture Wise It's like um it's an egg
yolk that has been matured kind of like
a fine vintage egg if that makes sense
uh last but not least we've got the
mixed vegetable and roasted chicken wrap
and of course we've got to have Congee
two types this is Century egg and this
is salted egg gives the century egg a
try
also yeah it's pretty strong there's a
very very fine line between tasty and
stinky and Century egg firmly Shadows
that line I've never had salted egg yolk
in a Congee before
ponji is not my favorite breakfast item
but I think with this kind of flavoring
that yeah I can dig it
and of course on every single breakfast
menu there's gonna be crispy Chinese
crawler the yotal they all look the same
no matter which fast food chain you go
to BK also has a sunny side up egg
although
again you can't really tell where the
sun is oh this is pretty interesting the
bean paste glutinous rice ball we call
them that far which kind of means Sesame
pile a mound these have a really
interesting history they originated in
the tangency over a thousand years ago
and were served up in the Imperial
Kitchen and actually you'll find that a
lot of traditional Chinese desserts
especially here in Beijing were
originally served to the emperor the
sort of stuff that we eat now
foreign back in the old days centuries
ago when Emperors ruled China history in
a mouthful
I'd say it's okay it's probably not the
tastiest Sesame Mound I've ever had but
you know this isn't made for Emperors
because otherwise I'll be off with your
head egg bacon pie
oh that's pretty tasty the nostalgia's
coming back in I just remember growing
up in the UK and then going down at
Greg's and getting a nice pasty in the
morning oh I've actually never had
Burger King breakfast in the U.S our
breakfast sandwiches all come with
different variations of sausage bacon
ham egg and cheese and they come in
either a croissant biscuit or melt form
we couldn't get the Melt form but we do
have the croissant and the biscuit in
the loaded versions loaded just means
that they come with all of the toppings
they look like they're about to burst so
I believe that's true in America this is
a biscuit
the salt that just got into I like I
felt all the moisture in my body just
disappeared with that one bite that was
crazy here are all the different
breakfast sandwich combinations that you
can make at Burger King in the U.S so
you can also get the enormous burrito or
its baby if you don't want that much of
a burrito before like 10 a.m We also
have sweeter breakfast options like
these pancakes with a sausage and the
French toast sticks
like it literally feels like I am
chewing gum right now that is crazy how
stretchy and bouncy it is right now they
smell
like they were just refried
it's also chewy just like the pancakes
but a lot less disturbing in the mouth
so Burger King entered China in 2005
which actually makes it late to the game
KFC and macades have already been here
for a decade by that point and Chinese
consumers know what western fast food is
like already BK cultivates a slightly
different image one of slightly more
Prestige and you'll find them mostly in
major cities top tier cities like
Beijing Shanghai less so in smaller
cities I feel
Burger King has the reputation of being
somewhat fresher when it comes to
ingredients maybe it's considered on the
more fresher side when it comes to
American fast food even though it's
probably not it's pretty funny in the
past Burger King has been criticized for
its bad customer service for its uh rude
servers and the main thing was you
couldn't even complain because they
didn't have a complaints hotline they
kind of like take it or leave it
convenience speed of service that
totally depends on your specific Burger
King is it fast food still Yes you still
get the food in around 10 to 15 minutes
it's just will you be getting what you
ordered
who knows that's part of the fun I would
say that Burger King out of McDonald's
and KFC is the least localized and so
they're cultivating maybe the image of
being a gourmet burger jointer sort of a
go-beteen regular fast food chain and an
actual gourmet burger restaurant when it
comes to how they adapt to local tastes
I feel like there's nothing that special
on the menu it's pretty normal American
fast food they did have that one special
Texas whopper which I've never been to
Texas so I can't really speak on how
accurate that is but it tasted really
good so in terms of competition bug
gigging is actually fifth in China
behind KFC McDonald's Wallace burger and
chicken which is a local brand and decos
another local brand McDonald's has to be
Burger King's biggest rival as we're
filming this in early May we've gotten
word that Burger King is closing around
300 to 400 locations
a Whopper is 27 Yen that's
3.92 in the US a whopper cost 7.89 which
is in 101.3 percent price increase
compared to China's Whopper
make it a meal with a medium fry and a
medium drink and the price goes up to 40
Yen which is 5.8 add a medium fry and a
drink to your order and that brings the
price up to 11.99 which is in 106.7
increase in price and if you want to
upgrade to large then that's 44 Yen
which is
6.38 make it a large in the US and the
price goes up to 12.59 which is a 97
increase in price just in general I
found that Burger King tends to be
slightly more expensive than McDonald's
and KFC
China's Burger King doesn't share its
nutritional information but here are a
few noteworthy moments from the last
couple of years in 2020 Burger King
apologized to its customers when it was
reported that some of their locations
had sold expired food so a Burger King
in Nanchang which is a major city in
Eastern China had used expired
ingredients to make its burgers and get
this there was actually video footage of
Staff replacing the date labels on the
expired bread with new ones and another
Burger King in exactly the same city did
the same thing with expired chicken
Burger King responded with and I quote
our mismanagement has betrayed the trust
of consumers to Burger King and we
express our deepest apologies for this
and this caused China to probe further
into outer U.S fast food chains like KFC
and McDonald's Burger King along with
McDonald's was Sue last year for using
pfas or forever chemicals in their
packaging forever chemicals it's in my
body forever Consumer Reports found pfas
in the French toast sticks bags Whopper
wrappers and chicken nugget bags we ate
like two out of those three things today
oh my God pfas are chemicals that are
hard to break down and last a long time
which are not good for the environment
and pfas exposure has been linked to
health problems in humans Burger King
has responded in saying quote the Burger
King brand has required that any added
perfluoro alcohol and polyfloral alkyl
substances pfas be phased out from all
approved guest-facing packaging
materials globally by the end of 2025 or
sooner that's not soon enough from
calorie counts to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Subway in the US and in China
this is food Wars
here in China standard Subway subs come
in two sizes
six inch and
all right
12 inch
they've done us the favor of cutting our
12 inch sub in half
how very kind in the US our subs also
come in two sizes a six inch or a 12
inch also known as the footlong we're
going to measure both of these with a
tape measure to make sure that those
lengths are actually correct what does
it look like is it right is it good
I would say it's like maybe a few
centimeters off of 12 inches but it's
close enough like I don't think you're
gonna notice a few centimeters of
Sandwich missing I'll give you a pass
Subway that's that's fine that's about
30.8 centimeters
12.12598 inches that one is six inches
for sure about 15 centimeters
5.9055 inches we can also get sub
platters in the US ours are the exact
same size five 12 inch subs cut into 15
pieces that is a lot of sandwich it's
very very heavy it's really heavy
I'm gonna leave it there we used to have
sub platters and party Subs but shows
over folks no more parties on this side
of the Pacific how's it look for you
Nico we used to have party Subs in the
US but Subway overhauled and streamlined
its menu last year and now seems to have
stopped offering them somebody check on
Joe right now because I know he is
devastating dated
moving on from Subs drinks at a Chinese
Subway only come in one size medium
that's just sad drinks at a U.S Subway
come in four sizes small 21 ounces
medium 30 ounces or large which is 40
ounces you may have noticed I said we
have four drink sizes that only showed
you three that's because on Subway's
catering menu in the US you'll find this
thank you to my beautiful assistant it's
a gallon of Hubert's lemonade this
supposedly serves eight people which
would be 16 fluid ounces each why is the
recommended serving size for this
lemonade smaller than the usual small
size that's very suspicious Subway but I
do love this lemonade so the large is
supposed to be 40 ounces we're gonna
measure it to see if I'm being lied to
basically the medium is meant to contain
473 milliliters of your drink let's see
how much is actually in there the coke
is really dark so it's kind of hard for
me to see the numbers but it did go
slightly above 32 ounces which is
significantly less than the 40 I was
promised and by the way this was with no
ice it's meant to be 473 milliliters but
I just wanted to show you look how much
is missing from the top this here is
about
425 ish and if that's the case it's
missing over 50 milliliters of my soda
what give Subway
[Music]
here's everything that you'll find at
Subway China that you won't find in the
US here's everything that you'll find at
a U.S Subway that you won't find in
China obviously Subway's menu is highly
customizable by combining different
ingredients Subway claims you can create
over 2 million sandwiches
I don't know if I believe that but I
also don't have the time and or money to
prove it so let's just say it's true now
let's start with the foundation of any
sandwich the bread now here in China we
have a couple of options and by a couple
I mean two that you don't have in the US
first is honey oat and the second is
Parmesan oregano now it's on the menu
but of all of the stores that we ordered
from they all changed out the Parmesan
oregano for just regular bread so I
don't know if they're offering it
anymore or it's just still on the menu
and they've forgotten to take it out and
in the US we also have exclusive bread
options like Artisan Flatbread and
Hearty multigrain once you've picked
your bread then it's time to choose your
fillings these are all of China's
exclusive fillings that you won't find
in the US starting with the black pepper
thick cut steak oh they weren't joking
when they said thick cut
I know
that's pretty decent here we have the
Italian sausage and
the chicken thigh chop it's always the
chicken thigh when it comes to chicken
meat in a burger because Chinese
people's thigh is the juicy part not the
breast next we've got the egg Mayo
series we love our egg Mayo here we've
got salami egg Mayo I will need to ask
for more salami next time four pieces
just doesn't cut it when you've got a
six inch sub there's also the tuna egg
Mayo I'm just gonna move swiftly onto
the chicken teriyaki egg Mayo the
Chinese name is quite descriptive it's
it's the parent and child sandwich
because obviously chicken and egg
put egg Mayo in a bun I'm happy here
we've got the teriyaki chicken sandwich
on honey oat bread it's not got egg Mayo
in it it's an inferior teriyaki chicken
the Full House which is tuna and chicken
oh it's a good thing none of you can
smell my breath right now
and here we've just got the bog standard
ham Save The Best For Last our pulled
pork limited edition sandwich with Chia
seeds in our bread I'm quite pleased
with the amount of meat that's found its
way into the Subway subs
a little bit too sweet for my taste
but the pulled pork is there we have a
ton of Subs in the U.S that aren't on
the Chinese menu so let's start with the
classic sandwiches so we've got the big
hop pastrami buffalo chicken chicken and
bacon ranch cold cut combo meatball
marinara oven roasted turkey and ham
steak and cheese and the veggie patty a
fast food meatball sub sounds difficult
so I kind of want to try it and see how
it tastes this is a very heavy sandwich
I just want to say it reminds me of
school lunch like the smell of walking
into a cafeteria when you're in like
seventh grade that's the vibe I'm
getting from it
it's an okay meatball sub so this is the
chicken bacon ranch I love chicken I
love bacon and I love ranch so hopefully
I like this sandwich there's just
something about how the meat looks
that's making my tummy hurt a little I
think it's just the paleness of the
chicken and bread
I mean it tastes better than it looks
next we have the no bready balls
starting with the black pepper steak egg
Mayo no bready bowl this actually looks
really good they've got some kidney
beans and some kind of coarse grain at
the bottom as well this actually looks
decent I am now this tastes really good
next we have the tuna egg Mayo no bready
bowl oh that does not look appetizing
the teriyaki chicken egg Mayo no bready
bowl but this is actually pretty decent
I think the no bready balls are probably
actually order again we also have the no
bready bowls which according to the menu
are different than a salad although they
look exactly like a salad a salad hidden
under a mountain of deli meats here are
all of the Us exclusive bready Bowls the
exclusive sandwiches don't stop there in
2022 Subway in the US launched a range
of menu items known as the subway series
it's a list of 12 Subs with
predetermined ingredients designed to
streamline the ordering process so
instead of going down the line and
picking every individual thing that you
want you can just order these off a menu
while prepping for this shoot we thought
we had most of the subs on the subway
series menu but since then we have found
out that they have dropped more
sandwiches on this menu the list just
seems to keep growing and I don't know
when they're gonna stop so let's just
focus on the subs that we have in front
of us right now I am very intrigued by
the monster that name sounds awful and
I'm hoping the sandwich will not be I
think it looks pretty good to me okay so
this is the monster which is steak bacon
and cheddar
that's delicious it's good the Bella
matzah I think that if I was any of the
sandwiches on this list I would want to
be this one because why wouldn't I want
to be the prettiest sandwich this one
definitely has like a more pleasing look
to it there's just like so much color in
it it looks like it has a lot of fresh
ingredients in it so in the Bella matzah
we have ham capicola and mozzarella all
delicious let's taste it
foreign
[Music]
I really really like it this feels very
classic sandwich to me like if I was
going to a sandwich shop I'd probably
order something like this so This Is The
All-American which has turkey ham and
bacon she looks pretty good
she's not really giving I think it's too
much onions I really really want to
taste the sliced Avo Mexicali this one
has rotisserie chicken avocado and
pepper jack that all sounds so good to
me oh she's saucy
I feel like I haven't seen much sauce
going on so this is different there's a
lot of sauce in there
it's good but I think the sandwich has
just been sitting here for so long that
the bread got soggy so the bread on the
bottom is like very very soft
but the actual Taste of the sandwich is
really really good it's honestly tasty
and Subway also offers wraps so here
we've got their black pepper steak wrap
oh yeah I think I prefer this version
next we have the teriyaki chicken wrap
smells a bit wet the turkey breast wrap
there's literally one slice of turkey
breast here we had the Italian sausage
wrap the sausage has been butterflied
it's just one sausage it's actually okay
after doing all of this Subway research
they actually added wraps onto our menu
here are all of the wraps that you can
get on the US menu
we also have a couple of exclusive meat
options in the U.S pepperoni and
capicola here in China we have some
meaty toppings that you won't find in
the US for example
shrimp which
they literally gave us in a paper bag
Subway will ask you if you want cheese
on your sub and we definitely have a lot
more cheese options than they have in
China both countries offer American or
shredded mozzarella but the U.S also
offers pepper jack provolone Swiss or
Monterey cheddar China has one sandwich
topping that you won't find in the U.S
and that's egg Mayo we love Eggman here
I love egg Mayo it's basically just
chunky Mayo with eggs inside and you'll
find it in over half of our offerings
here in China Subway you have it in Subs
you have it in wraps and you have it in
protein bowls as well all of these are
egg Mayo it's delicious when it comes to
vegetable toppings both the U.S and
China offer tomatoes lettuce cucumber
pickles green pepper black olives red
onions and jalapenos but the U.S also
carries banana peppers my favorite
spinach and avocado we also have some
exclusive sauces like barbecue and
thousand island dressing and then
there's also Mayo honey mustard black
pepper sauce and olive oil it's kind of
shocking that we don't have thousand
island dressing as an option it's not
like a super common sandwich spread at
least not in my house but you do see it
on Reubens and stuff like that exclusive
sauces in the U.S include oil red wine
vinegar creamy Sriracha buffalo sauce
MVP parmesan vinaigrette and roasted
garlic aioli
they shove these words in everywhere you
guys are like trying to Gaslight me into
thinking that this is like an athlete's
favorite food and I know that's not true
it's crazy it's crazy What's Happening
Here MVP parmesan vinaigrette isn't real
you made that up speaking of trying to
make me think that athletes love Subway
here are the athlete collabs here we
have the avocado Spike bowl by Rob
Gronkowski the no-look chicken by
Patrick Mahomes the front Court Feast by
Charles Barkley the meatball Marksman by
Steph Curry and then there's the danger
witch
let's talk about the danger witch Once
Upon a Time this was Russell Wilson's
Subway collab sandwich I don't know what
happened but at some point they removed
his name from the sandwich I think it
has something to do with this weird
commercial they did promoting the danger
witch you ever done anything dangerous
I obviously can't confirm anything but
I'm dying to try this so let's see what
the danger witch tastes like
they probably should get rid of it in
general because it's also just not a
very good sandwich mostly just tastes
like mustard now it's tradition on food
Wars to combine all of one country's
exclusives together I present to you the
us only sub
it has bacon pepper jack cheese banana
peppers spinach buffalo sauce all on
jalapeno cheddar bread I think our
specific Subway didn't have jalapeno
cheddar bread this is their other cheesy
bread but it's the closest thing we got
it mostly just tastes like bacon which
I'm not upset about this is the China
only sub black pepper steak
egg Mayo
Thousand Island dressing
on honey oat bread let's see if you guys
in the states are missing out you know
egg Mayo goes on absolutely anything
and the
thick cut steak
gives it a nice bump yeah I'd order this
again now let's see what side options we
have in the U.S chips in general seem to
be more of a U.S exclusive here are all
the flavors I was able to get my hands
on at our location so we have three lace
flavors there's sour cream and onion
classic and barbecue
we also have two baked glaze flavors the
original and barbecue we have Doritos in
both cool ranch and nacho cheese two
flavors of Miss Vicki's chips we have
jalapeno and spicy dill pickle and we
have three flavors of Sun Chips we have
garden salsa original and harvest
cheddar you can also get a gogo squeeze
applesauce as a kids side Subway also
has sides namely ratan pepper popcorn
chicken so I would assume that this is
meant to be sutrani Style Chicken in
that it should be spicy and also make
your mouth pleasantly numb
just the tiniest hint of chili heat here
we've got some potato balls
it just tastes like hash browns now this
is pretty unique this is called western
region style roast chicken wings usually
when you say something is western region
flavored they usually mean lamb or cumin
no that's pretty good no potato chips
here we're super healthy but we do have
cookies now both the US and China each
have an exclusive cookie here in China
we have the
Peach oolong
hmm
that's quite Pleasant and Subway in the
U.S offers the raspberry cheesecake
cookie I love Subway cookies they are
surprisingly soft and definitely the
best cookie in fast food in my opinion I
just think that they're so good
it's amazing as I suspected and finally
we have drinks I am very happy that
Subways in the U.S carry Coke products
you can get a classic Coca-Cola a little
DC Sprite Dasani which
my favorite Vitamin Water triple X Gold
Peak sweet tea simply lemonade orange or
apple Honest Kids super fruit punch or a
hubris lemonade for drinks China carries
soy milk and PepsiCo products so you can
get Pepsi Pepsi light 7Up Tropicana you
can also get Aquafina water and it's
soda water variety but I guess only in
select sauce because when we ordered we
ended up getting non-full spring which
is kind of like the Chinese version of
Evian I would say now Subway enter China
relatively late in 2005 and I believe
Nationwide they've got about 700 stores
when they first opened they had a lot
more presents than they do now they've
kind of slid Into Obscurity and they're
only really found in major cities like
Beijing and Shanghai sandwiches aren't
really hot in China people don't like
cold bread cold sandwiches of course you
can ask for your sandwich heated up but
just the fact that it's kind of a
cold sandwich as a default is a bit of a
turn off I think you can tell there
hasn't been much localization on the
Subway menu I mean there's the egg Mayo
there's the western region chicken but
cold custom-made sandwiches are not
really the first thing you think of when
you want food in China you can probably
guess that Subway is in a bit of a sad
State here in China in terms of
competition I mean there's no need to
even try to compete with KFC McAdoo
they're so far ahead completely left
Subway in the dust
is getting their subs for Less a foot
long Italian BMT from a Chinese Subway
costs 47 Yen that's 6.79 at the time of
recording a footlong Italian BMT from a
U.S Subway costs 9.99 I was so curious
as to what BMT means and it apparently
stands for biggest meatiest tastiest
I don't know if I like that that makes
the U.S sandwich this much more
expensive Subway pricing has been a
contentious subject in the US for a
while now you guys might remember the
infamous Five Dollar Foot long promotion
Subway operated for a really long time
it was pulled after franchisee said it
was costing them too much money Subway
has repeatedly attempted to bring it
back but it's been quickly killed every
single time
thank you
I have a feeling that U.S Subway will be
more unhealthy than China's Subway so
let's compare a classic turkey sub a six
inch oven roasted turkey sub in the U.S
is 270 calories now Subway China hasn't
released its nutritional information but
based on Independent third-party
research I can tell you that a six inch
oven roasted turkey sub here in China is
252 calories
or 270 depending on who you talk to the
most calorific sandwich you can get is
the chicken and bacon ranch which clocks
in at 570 calories I want to guess the
most caloric sandwich in Subway China I
think it has to be the black pepper
thick cut steak am I right close a six
inch black pepper thick cut is 415
calories but our heaviest hitter is in
fact the six inch tuna sandwich clocking
in at 450 calories not only is it not
tasty it's also incredibly colorific is
it in my food or not is it in my food or
not is it like touching the food
is it in the gloves is it in the hats is
it in this little crown that I've been
wearing all day I'm so stressed out